so there's a tragic story coming out of
uh Texas a mass shooting and leftist
researchers in the corporate press are
running with this story that they've
discovered the profile of this
individual and lo this Mexican man is
actually a white supremacist now the
thing is it seems like researchers have
uh dug through this profile it does not
seem to be real this person was posting
weird things in the past couple of weeks
to no followers and to no one but of
course the media is going to run with it
in this there are on this profile there
are posts about Libs of tick tock and I
believe it's four clips from this show
from one particular episode that was
enough for them to come out and yeah now
Tim pool is trending and claim that this
individual was a fan of this show yeah
I'm gonna come out outright and just be
like you're Liars that's not the case
you don't get to say someone posted a
clip one time and you're a fan because
by that metric Media Matters is our
biggest fan shout out to Media Matters
for being huge fans of of this show but
come on that's ridiculous and we and we
all know it I think the real issue here
is a tragedy happened and of course once
again the left is trying to weaponize it
for political points we saw what
happened in Nashville only a month or so
ago and it was a tragic story they still
have not released the manifesto but it
was really really bad this the shooter
was transgender many people had
questions about what the motivations
were and we haven't gotten the manifesto
and all of a sudden the next time you
get some major tragedy they discover
this profile that just so happens to
implicate those demanding the manifesto
the one thing I can say to all of this
I'm not going to do what PewDiePie did
and come out and be like oh I'm so sorry
dude we are one of the biggest podcasts
in the world I'm not trying to Humble
brag we have one of the largest live
audience on on YouTube every night so a
lot of people watch the show and not
everybody who watches it likes the show
so y'all can go shove it but I I think
you're full of it and I quite literally
don't care what the cult thinks anyway
we're gonna keep doing what we do but
we're going to talk about this story
because it does involve us and as I'm
going through the news there's my name
trending alongside Libs of tick tock who
I think does very great and important
work so we'll talk about all of that but
my friends before we do head over to
castbrew.com and pick up this delicious
rise with Roberto Jr breakfast Blend
Coffee castbrew.com it's our coffee
company we're sponsoring ourselves so
every time you buy your coffee from cast
Brew you're basically helping support
our Ventures we've got rides with
Roberto Jr we got Appalachian nights we
also have a Colombian roast and a French
roast and with every purchase of rise
with Roberto Jr you also receive a
picture of Roberto Jr our rooster right
there in the back of the bag and I know
that picture will will inspire you and
comfort you in your darkest of times so
uh casper.com if you want to support the
show and pick up some coffee and also
head over to timcast.com click that join
us button become a member support the
show directly and you'll get access to
our uncensored members only shows Monday
through Thursday at 8pm we're gonna have
one of those up for you tonight and you
can get access to our Discord server
where you can actually submit questions
and call into the show so support our
work smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the share with your
friends joining us today to talk about
this and so much more is Kyle Serafin
here I am who are you what do you do so
I'm a former FBI agent I say recovering
FBI agent it's actually a lot easier to
explain to people it's kind of like
being an alcoholic when you're part of
something that you didn't want to be
part of and maybe you can step away from
that I spent six years with the FBI and
then another year unpaid where they
claimed I was an employee but they took
my badge they took my gun I didn't have
any responsibilities I wasn't allowed to
claim that I was an FBI employee but
they claimed it which is an interesting
kind of move sometimes when you work
with the government you get this very
weird one-sided power relationship but I
started off as a whistleblower in uh
2021 in October that doesn't usually go
over very well the first thing I did was
expose something about the the FBI going
after parents at school board meetings
wow so once you start doing that you
might as well pot commit to it and go
all the way so we've exposed a bunch of
stuff I've worked with project Veritas
in the past and then most recently we
exposed something about how the FBI was
going to investigate radical traditional
Catholics which is always a good move
because everyone knows there's nothing
closer to a white supremacist than a
person who likes the Latin Mass so that
was one of the games and anyway I just
full-time sort of anti-anti what do they
call anti-government anti-authority
violent extremists I think that's the
way that they probably tagged me in
their files and uh got a spying on you
so when they claimed that parents were
terrorists that information came out
because you blew the whistle yeah there
were two of us I don't know who the
other person was I was the first one
that brought it to my congresswoman in
New Mexico and um essentially I read it
and you know there was this sort of
backlash where they said oh we're not
going to be investigating parents it's
like well it's actually called the
Federal Bureau of Investigation for a
reason it's it's actually what they do
if you think that they just do
intelligence things it's because they're
doing investigations so that's how it
started and um you know once once you
start down that road uh you're probably
not long for working for government
agencies but uh it turns out you also
get to keep your integrity which is
helpful right on man thanks for hanging
out this should be uh this should be
interesting we got Seamus Coughlin yeah
dressed all nice absolutely and by the
way good for you man that's really
incredible work I'm glad you blew the
whistle on that stuff especially someone
who goes to the Latin mass and also
someone who doesn't like what these
groomers school boards are doing to kids
and thinks that parents should be fully
empowered to stand up to them but my
name is Seamus Coughlin I create
cartoons at a YouTube channel called
Freedom tunes and I also have a podcast
on Rumble called shamer if y'all want to
check that out I'm excited for a nice
show
hi everybody I am uh Phil Labonte lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and this is my homie
my name is serge.com I'm excited for
this evening it'll be fun to talk to you
um let's get started I think Ian got
abducted you know he's just gone but
like he woke up and he wasn't here
anymore oh my God so you know he's in
there we got the former FBI guy here
all right let's jump into that to my
knowledge that's correct it's an ongoing
investigation that we can't make any
comments about it let's jump into this
first story We Have This from NBC News
what we know about the slain Texas mall
Massacre suspect Mauricio Garcia Garcia
with a tactical vest was armed with a
rifle and a handgun a senior law
enforcement official said authorities
said he was a suspected Neo-Nazi
sympathizer now this story is it's a
tragedy it's unfortunate and um we have
unfortunately too many of these stories
that end up happening in the media I'm
sorry that end up happening and then end
up hitting the media so I mean the first
thing I just want to say before we get
in any of the politics from either side
is yeah we don't want these things to
happen we want these things to stop we
need to figure out what the the issue is
in our society and our culture I
genuinely believe it's disassociation it
is it is a dejected Society where
individuals don't know or care about
each other and they seek validation or
they seek to push some extremist
ideology and then this whole thing
creates a recipe for disaster I'll put
it simply I think it's multiculturalism
and not the idea that people of all
different types are holding hands on the
rainbow it's that you have different
communities stacked on top of each other
and next to each other with wildly
different views and they don't like each
other and then people who are crazy will
do crazy things but what ends up
happening today
we have the story from the Daily Mail
revealed Texas gunman staked out
Massacre mall to monitor peak times
three weeks before killing eight and
posted details on Russian social media
alongside photos of Nazis guns and
ammunition you see here's where we get
into the psy op
no one knows if this Russian social
media profile is actually but it
actually belongs to this guy a
bellingcat researcher named Eric Toler
just said I found this profile that
looks like it's his in fact I'm pretty
sure he even said I didn't verify it I
don't know now the photos that are
coming out I don't want to show many of
them considering the sensitive nature of
these things they don't show his face
and Ian miles Chong actually found that
most of these photos are from five years
ago on a random subreddit that we're
making fun of these people so the whole
story seems to be strange but let's jump
to this from Andy no
he says the Brown face of white
supremacy a leftist bellingcat writer
has posted screenshots from the
purported Obscure odd not how do you
pronounce this
Nikki social media profile of the Allen
Texas mass shooter Mauricio Garcia he's
trying to link the shooter to Tim cast
and Libs of tick tock the account has
photos of random Latino people wearing
or posing in front of Neo-Nazi symbols
balinket is a government-funded site
that was sourcing from intelligence
agencies it employs radical leftist
writers and then I think I've got uh do
I have Ian miles Chong here
Ian miles Chong says posting on Blue Sky
Media Matters for America register
Parker Malloy tells former Twitter uh
trust and safety head yellow Roth that
not Banning Libs of tick tock may have
caused the Allen Texas mass shooting and
then we have this so stupid now now we
know but this is the left argument for
everything shut up or there will be more
mass shootings if you don't say your
point or there will be more mass
shootings that's their argument that's
all it is the whole point is they want
to connect the anyone that would speak
in a way that they do not approve of and
which is essentially their in control of
they want to link them to any kind of
bad thing that they can I mean you look
at timcast and you know it was swatted
15 times last year here and and they're
saying that plus bomb threats yeah and
they're saying that that Tim cast is
causing stochastic terrorism even though
they continue like the there's leftists
that are constantly saying oh Tim Cass
does this and they do this and blah blah
it's like it's literally the iron law of
woke projection can we can we change the
name researcher to propaganda this
because I think it's more accurate and
it feels more genuine if we just let's
just call it what it is what they are
you can't be a researcher for Belling
cat or Media Matters if you have an
agenda if you're hold you're pushing an
agenda yeah if your whole job is to to
look for people that have a different
political opinion and then cast them in
the most negative light imaginable
you're not a journalist you're not a
researcher you are a propagandist so
they're leftist propagandists they're
just commies they're just I mean they're
just commies I I I really just don't
care because I think they they've just
lost I just I I feel nothing of this
well they're they're at the ad hominem
level right they're attacking they're
attacking you they're saying You must be
obviously affiliated with I thought by
the way the uh the Brown face of white
supremacy was Larry Elder I'm pretty
sure
oh there's a big difference there this
is the brown error on your part but it's
okay yeah all right yeah end of the day
though when they start getting into the
the ad hominem attacks like they've
already lost the argument there is no
fundamental argument against it they're
gonna attack your character they're
gonna attack your your values but it
doesn't have anything to do with what
like did they make a strong point where
they think this guy was somehow there
there was a four episode where the media
had enough influence to where I may have
been concerned about this and then been
like oh do I got to put out a statement
I remember when uh New Zealand shooting
happened and the guy said subscribe to
PewDiePie or whatever right and then
PewDiePie was all like yo oh man like
hey look John I'm kind of just like shut
up I look at this and I'm like shut your
mouth Belling cat you guys are
idiots you get me swearing but like it's
a it's a random profile from Russia The
credibility is almost nothing and
there's four clips from one show one
time and so I just look at this and I'm
like let me tell you all a story about
when the Southern Poverty Law Center
found a holocaust denying conspiracy
theory website from Iran that listed me
as a speaker I have never been to Iran
and then claimed that I was a speaker
and they had to retract and delete it
and apologize because the best part the
best part was this me and a few other
people threatened a lawsuit saying like
how could you just say this ridiculous
fake garbage and they knew typically
when it comes to defamation lawsuits
they're really hard but what they would
have to say is either they knew it was
fake or me uh Southern party Law Center
believes that Holocaust denying
conspiracy websites based in Iran that
were previously deleted and then hosted
as an archive are credible sources of
information that they rely on and I was
like I'd be willing to accept them
winning the case if they state that
publicly that would be fantastic yeah
you know they come out and say we we do
often find Archives of conspiracy theory
websites based in Iran as and and use
that as relevant facts for our sourcing
so I look at this
and I just say one thing wow they must
be really desperate the the transgender
shooter in Nashville must have terrified
them to the Bone because the other day
when we were in Miami I was hanging out
at Hard Rock Seminole and this is what
people were talking about you hear what
just happened and in you know in Texas
and I was like yeah and then someone
goes and that Nashville thing with that
that transgendered person and I'm like
uh oh when a regular dude who doesn't
know a whole lot about anything is
talking about that stuff you can see
exactly why they're freaking out well
this is the apple of discord too right
so it's it's that Golden Apple it says
to the fairest it's just a shiny object
they toss it in the middle of the room
it doesn't have to have any meaning
behind it other than whatever you
ascribe to it and people on the left
have ascribed exactly what they want to
feel they fill in all the blanks it
doesn't matter that it's weak Russian it
doesn't matter that it's not backstopped
that's what we call that in the
intelligence world there's no backstop
behind it right it doesn't go deep
enough for there to be any kind of
validity and yet it says what I wanted
to say yeah it pegs my enemy in the way
that I wanted to Peg them so it's
effective and nobody looked into it any
further because they don't care they're
not trying to find truth what they're
trying to find is am I reaffirmed in my
belief whether it's that they hate you
or that they hate uh you know that it's
it's obviously guns and white supremacy
and all the other things that they're
gonna demonize I don't just toss that
shiny object in there I I I really do
Wonder like what is the what is the end
goal of of trying to to claim this guy
was a fan of Libs of tick tock or Tim
cast it has nothing to do with us what
band what why would we get banned I know
I I think it would be ridiculous for
them to ban you but that's not gonna
happen but that's the angle that they're
trying to go with this is that's why
they're talking about it that's why your
enemies are continually bringing this up
I just I disagree I disagree I get your
point maybe that's the intention but
it's just like there's literally nothing
they can do the the the it is it doesn't
work that way with Alex Jones they
desperately try to find anything and
this was several years ago but the media
has lost so much
power and influence they may as well be
posting this I mean they're literally
posting it on they don't know it no
they're on Blue Sky it's like do we know
do you guys know what blue sky is no no
no you've never heard of it okay well
you do I do but the average person's
like I haven't Tim I know you're talking
about yeah this is a dude cartoon all
right jack dorsey's new thing yeah
they're on some obscure website spitting
into the wind and it's laughable but I
got coverage in the Daily Mail they
don't mention me or lives of tick tock
okay so the thing that's fun about it I
mean obviously they're trying to
accomplish an agenda and they also
haven't realized that they've lost all
their Capital so they're spending money
that has no value right so they're out
there spending this they're attempting
to do something with this sort of
website with this sort of story but it
doesn't get any traction but it used to
and they're doing the same thing it's
like it's like a toddler that's still
throwing Tantrums when you know that
they're not going to pass out they're
not going to die if they pass out so
you're letting them pass out so now
they're throwing the Tantrums and those
Tantrums come out exactly what you'd
expect it's like we're just gonna watch
you until you stop there's no there's no
outcome to this that's going to be
beneficial so exactly but who cares like
let them let himself I got some direct
messages from people and they were like
whoa what's going on and I was like I
always tell people don't send me stuff
when people like I I've got so many
people saying so much stupid crap about
me all day every day I literally don't
care you know today you know what what
are we doing I'm having some sea bass
for dinner complaining on the internet
that's about it this is meaningless it's
it's unfortunate what happened in Texas
but the left is looking for any kind of
political angle you take a look at what
happened after Nashville they claimed
the trans person was one of the victims
exactly they're trying desperately to
spend this so you want to bring this
stuff up I will dedicate a whole SEC a
whole segment to uh the national you
know what Let's do let's let's do it
here we go you know um you asked for it
you get it you get you you get what uh
what you ask for my friends hey let's
jump to this next story from the Daily
Mail National Police Association sues to
make trans Nashville school shooter
Audrey Hills Manifesto public days after
cop said they were pausing plans to
release it due to pending litigation the
National Police Association filed the
suit on April 28th for the release of
the Audrey Hills penned Manifesto calls
for the release of Hale's manuscript has
have grown since hail opened fire on the
Covenant School in Nashville so here we
have a story about a transgender woman
who killed three children and faculty
members and we still don't know the
official reason but how funny is it that
a day after what happens in Texas
researchers funded by and supported by
intelligence agencies just happened to
have found an obscure Russian social
media profile that was posting to no one
with no followers yes sorry I I I'm just
I'm not going to buy it but you know
like if regular people want to believe
this stuff I don't care it's true it's
not like it was his Facebook page it's
not like he was his Twitter account it's
not like he had some YouTube page with a
ton of stuff on it I think that I read
that there is a YouTube page but it
wasn't it wasn't extensive so the whole
idea that that there's this this long
history of him watching these things and
blah blah these are very very
superficial and only surface level
connections and they're doing everything
they can to make it you know about about
it's the spaghetti technique exactly yes
you throw it against the wall you see
what sticks and none of this is going to
stay this week and you said it's not
backstop it's not shorts what's
interesting too is look National Police
Association is the one suing for it and
I don't claim to speak for all law
enforcement but I know enough people
that work in the law enforcement world
that's the background that I came out of
and I've got buddies who are former cops
I got buddies that are former federal
agents they all want this thing public
there's no excuse for not exposing it
and and so generally speaking people and
that's that's the nice thing about this
story is that you see there is someone
from the National Police Association
putting money behind a lawsuit saying we
are trying to get this thing out I
guarantee you the people that work for
Nashville PD want it out too they want
to because their officers responded in a
Flawless way technically like
outstanding response to what happened
right they went out there and they
solved the problem in a way that and
when you look at those guys like they
were not they were not gung-ho about
being that that wasn't the day they
planned the guy even gave his press
conference I thought it was really
emotional but they want this thing out
too because they want to say look this
is evil in the world we're calling it
out that's what you sign up today this
is a good example of the big problem of
our attention spans in society in that
when the cops do a bad job they get all
the attention in the world when it comes
to Uvaldi their story story non-stop
questions why did this happen how did
this happen and uh we don't give enough
attention or gratitude to the officers
who do the job right as tragic as it is
but they rush in you I mean that body
camera footage of what happened it's
it's it's it's it's crazy it's going to
be taught in tactical uh so the the
actual techniques are called alert
that's the training that people go
through it's a law enforcement standard
across the country it comes out of the
Texas State University in San Marcos put
out this thing after Columbine because
they said we got to standardize the idea
that we're going to have cops going into
these scenarios and they're going to do
it the right way so they wrote the book
on it I have the book actually in my
garage and they teach it at multiple
different levels these guys executed a
master class in that because you never
know all the information
they got keys to the doors that's a huge
just a heads up move they rolled in they
they had comms they had one guy that was
driving everything they had another guy
that was doing you know you know people
get tax saturated they go into a room
and they just all they can pay attention
to is staying alive because there's a
potential shooter behind every door and
they went right to that threat as soon
as they heard something they changed
tactics I mean these guys crushed it and
they should be the focus there should be
they should be at the White House yes
absolutely losers show up at the White
House and get medals for you know Medals
of Freedom these guys did the thing they
I I did a whole show on this called the
Super Bowl of masculinity but it's
essentially like imagine you woke up in
the morning you put on your pants like
you normally do you went and you started
your car you had your coffee you went to
go do your thing and suddenly it's like
today's your day to be a man at the
highest level that you can be a man
you're going to save children and put
your life on the line right now and no
one's giving you any warning you're
getting tapped from nowhere to step into
the Super Bowl and throw a touchdown
pass and those guys completed the pass
and they crushed it and they and
everyone now knows you will get no
you'll get Limited gratitude that's
right limited they they won't give you a
week of air time like they give the bad
cops you will not be invited to the
White House no book deal no book deal
well I mean look it's human nature right
uh good things just happen bad things
are somebody's fault
hmm
that's intense yeah yeah that's really
sobering and honestly it's really sad
too yeah because that is there there was
a time when we did celebrate Heroes that
did heroic things this country used to
understand that and now it's about the
the media cycle which generates clicks
and then likes and it's got to be rage
based not only it is I think there's a
good there's an argument to be made that
on the left there was more celebration
of the shooter than there was of the
police officers who went in there and
took them out so you saw those left-wing
protesters going there were seven
victims here unbelievably insane and
then you also had the media going out
and engaging in not only apologetics
for the left-wing narrative but
essentially for the act of violence that
took place if it was motivated by
left-wing ideology imagine right imagine
we had nailed down conclusive proof that
the reason that this Maniac committed
this recent shooting was because he was
a white supremacist and he did this
because he believed there was a white
genocide etc etc imagine if when the
media was talking about it they followed
up the story of the event with but white
people are having their rights taken
away and there is an effort to import
other people to replace they claimed he
was a victim and this shooter was a
victim but that is literally exactly
what happened I know I know and so it
makes it even more insane but that is
literally exactly what happened when
this trans person shot a bunch of
children all the stories were now we
should remind you that trans rights are
under threatened this country though
there is really a trans genocide etc etc
etc well on that last point I think
there is you know well the left do well
because the left is sterilizing that
right with Lance you know we talked
about the left Lexus is a trans genocide
and I'm like well I agree I think it's
when you sterilize trans people it's
prevent them from reproducing um that's
not I seriously think so I mean it's
terrifying well yeah I would prefer it
if they would stop but it's right out of
Rules for Radicals though right accuse
your opponent of what you're doing they
accuse us of being genocidal for saying
don't sterilize kids
and people believe it it's ridiculous
well so will we get do you guys think
we'll get the manifesto the police have
already intimated this was I think that
said it was politically motivated
motivated by resentment and the rumors
I've heard from uh various sources is
that it it seems to explicitly reference
conservatives trying to restrict child
sex change surgery
I've heard the same and I I will say
whether this comes out or not could be
dependent on whether there are people in
the intelligence agencies who are
willing to blow the whistle like you did
yes and if if it's actually first of all
somebody read this that was picking up
this was going to be a Frontline cop
this is somebody who's conducting the
search warrant at the house that was
conducting the search of the premises
that booked it into evidence this thing
had some eyes on it right that's why
we're getting some of the information
we're getting so some of those people
they you know they the sad thing is this
our country used to celebrate a look
behind the curtain a look into sort of
like what the government is up to when
they're keeping it from us that's what
the New York the New York Times used to
do that sort of thing classified
documents being leaked that was a
celebration on behalf of the media
because they said we're going to hold
the powerful to account and journalism
used to be a blue-collar Endeavor and
now what we see is they defend whatever
that narrative is on the behalf of the
government we were talking before we
started but it's like when did the kids
stop being so punk rock yeah like the
whole game used to be that whatever the
man wants I'm going to do the opposite
even if it's dumb for me the kids are
not doing that the band The Offspring
has a song on their first album that I
cannot say the name of
if I say the name of one of the songs on
their first album and anybody can Google
it it would likely result in some
attitudes knocking on my door the next
day let me just put it that way they the
name of the song is a direct threat on
government officials telling instructing
people to do a thing and they had that
song available I think for like 10 or 12
years until I had it on cassette the
song I'm pretty sure yeah you probably
did I had the first album said and then
you definitely did and uh this was punk
rock and then they got famous and Rich
and now their uh guitar player has me
blocked on Twitter talk about like just
crazy even the idea it's it's not Punk
it's not punk you know well I think
Gavin McGinnis said it he said the most
punk rock thing in the world you could
do right now is like marry somebody of
the opposite sex and then go make some
babies and take them to church and raise
you know human beings that pay taxes
like that's punk rock right it's funny
that's what my wife and I are doing it's
the funniest thing you can imagine but
you look over and there's there's memes
too where they say like what you thought
the resistance and the rebellion was
going to look like what it actually
looks like right and what you thought it
looked like was like people burning
stuff in the streets and having the
zombie apocalypse you know fight back
yeah and what it looks like is like
people homesteading and growing a garden
you know having having their own animals
like you guys do here so a lot of that
is you know the resistance is not what
people think it is but uh but that's
because kids stop being punk rock they
stop looking talking to resist whatever
the mainstream is and we're talking
about boot lickers it's the same thing
it's like apparently that's a virtue now
well it's it's also funny because like
99 of the people who will call you a
boot licker like want higher taxes and
to live in a pod and eat bugs yeah
govern Me Harder right yeah exactly you
know it's it's remarkable how quickly it
changes even up until 2021 the idea of
Revolution or Revolt or Insurrection
were celebrated I remember during the
George Floyd BLM riots there were left
Wingers posting online hey conservatives
who claim you care about the Second
Amendment now would be a good time to
rise up against the government since
they're violating our human rights and
then January comes around oh my goodness
we're in a country full of
insurrectionists how could the right
wing tread and of course we all know j6
wasn't an Insurrection it's all nonsense
but the point still stands because they
labeled an Insurrection now Insurrection
is a No-No but they were they were
literally fans of it when people were
burning down cities when the White House
was surrounded and the barricades were
broken down and they forced the
government and the president Into the
Bunker and the gravel Institute tweeted
that they thought it was good that it
happened but it was just the wrong
people Mark Hughes yeah it's all Herbert
it's all standard leftist tactics we
talk about this stuff all the time and
we I mean but they're not changing their
minds no they're not and they're not
gonna change it because I think
so here's the thing I I was in Portland
when they had the riots I did an
undercover surveillance Mission there
for about about two weeks uh which was
interesting and spicy there were things
that were pretty Rowdy I watched a
7-Eleven get taken over that was really
weird there were dudes on the top of the
7-Eleven across from the Portland Police
bureau's Union Hall which is like their
you know wherever their Union meets and
they were throwing Fireworks off there
you know explosive devices that could
have done real damage and at the same
time I was also outside of Lafayette
Square the day after they burned it and
they burned St John's Church we were
standing there Toe to Toe with Secret
Service guys who had caught bricks in
the head and nobody seemed to be upset
about it and then the other crazy thing
that you'd see was these like and it's
always these lib leftist women which are
ubiquitous and UDC they they were
bringing snacks for the protesters so
they're bringing like bags of granola
bars and stuff to fuel the rioters later
on that night and they're putting them
on top of piles of bricks and I'm like
one why are there loose bricks here on
the street this seems like a security
problem we're gonna solve that also what
are you trying to do because I guarantee
if you had done something like that for
January 6th let's say you were running
like a you know know Riot ribs outside
of the January 6 uh you know the protest
you would be hit with like some sort of
like providing material support to
terrorism I guarantee it it would have a
266 case on you from the FBI and they'd
be banging on your door to take your rib
you know your rib uh smoker yeah and
most of the people who got your ribs are
probably been feds too
this is for feeding government workers
without a permit
[Laughter]
it's infuriating but at the same time
getting upset and and sitting there
complaining about the hypocrisy is
absolutely counterproductive to it's
really a better position to just expect
it and try to anticipate what their
stories are going to be and just go
about your day and and make sure that
you have you know some kind of some kind
of uh response but for the most part
it's just like look you're they're gonna
say that stuff and you have to continue
going about your your day and doing what
you're doing because they're gonna call
you names they're gonna try and lay
everything on you that's the leftist
tactic is blame the other a person for
the things that they're doing you know
do as much as they can to discredit you
in front of other people and that way
people they throw them out without like
absolutely they don't care if there's
any background to it I got a letter from
the FBI in February stating that I was
racist sexist and or with a slash
homophobic during the six weeks I was in
the office when I didn't talk to anybody
in uh in May and April is that right no
March and April of last year and I
didn't talk to anybody I sat there and
I'm like and or like which one of these
was I is there any story is there any
background is there substance and this
is a legitimate you know government
agency semi-legitimate at least uh
nominally a constitutional group that
theoretically would have to put some
information behind it they put that out
there and so I shared it on Twitter
because I don't care like I just think
it's funny so I and people go hey you're
really slacking off you could have been
transphobic and xenophobic and you
missed the boat and it's like ah I
obviously yeah if you didn't get enough
of these if you're not getting enough
insults lobbed your way you're not
actually doing the job Let's uh let's
jump into the next story we have this
from the post millennial breaking full
footage reveals former Marine Daniel
Penny putting Jordan Neely in recovery
position passengers complimenting him
let me just put this in simple terms for
all of you the story of the violent
homeless man who is threatening to hurt
everyone who said he didn't care if he'd
go to jail who was subdued by three men
he died the left has called for this
former Marine's criminal prosecution and
indictment and AOC is referred to it as
a murder and as it turns out new footage
proves that this morning was actually
attempting to save the life of this man
of course I don't think AOC cares I
think she's maliciously evil and that
what these people truly want is anarcho
tyranny if you're a criminal you'll get
all of the defense in the world and if
you are the innocent civilian trying to
live your life they will beat you down
and blame you for everything
so the story here I suppose really
interesting is that um the reason this
video wasn't discovered immediately was
because it was taken by an individual
who doesn't speaks English as their
first language and so it was uploaded in
Spanish and it was then found in a
Spanish language Facebook post and then
uploaded thus debunking the whole
narrative surprise surprise another
Covington scenario the left goes nuts
calls for blood and then the video
surfaces later proving this guy actually
was trying to save this dude there's no
there was no question about like he
wasn't trying to kill the guy he was
trying to prevent him from hurting other
people and it sucks that he died but
it's not like it's it's probably
incompetence or whatever fine but he
wasn't intentionally trying to kill the
man but he doesn't have the standard
that law enforcement would have to
execute a move like this right because
he's a civilian bystander that has no
specialized training in that now he has
combative training he was a marine he
knows how to do a choke hold but if you
were going to do this thing properly
you'd probably do what's called a
carotid restraint a blood choke right
you want to get the the blood stopping
and you don't want to stop the the
breathing so he could have done
something he did an air choke it sounds
like but you could see his elbow
probably was a little bit too it needs
to be centered on there end of the day
and it doesn't matter in this video he's
still breathing the guy was still
breathing still moving and still trying
to get up and they put him in the
recovery position I teach emergency
medicine I used to teach it even at the
uh at the FBI's Academy I've been a
paramedic for over a decade and So based
Hands-On medicine you can do it with
almost nothing and what he did there is
textbooked Excellence for a bystander
that you could save people's lives by
putting them in a place where they're
they're trachea is going to be open that
they can actually get air he put them in
that left lateral recoverment position
which is what you do when people are
knocked out unconscious you can do it to
drunks there's a story from a year ago
where a homeless belligerent man
walk up to a woman who was standing on
the subway and shoved her right in front
of the terrain as I was coming killing
her so and there were 25 or so incidents
last year of that happening
so you get imagine you're on the train
and you keep hearing about violent
homeless people murdering people or
you've heard a couple times and you've
heard about 25 people they tried to kill
then someone gets in your train you're
trapped your Train's moving and they say
they're gonna hurt somebody and they
don't care if they go to jail three
people who live in New York thought it
would be reasonable to attempt to subdue
this man
I'm not going to then put the
responsibility on the marine trying to
stop a violent criminal I mean he's been
he was arrested 40 times he kidnapped a
kid before he punched him in the face
yep accurate if he doesn't know how to
do anything other than what he did it's
not his fault I don't blame the victims
of the crime for doing whatever they can
to try and stop themselves from being
victims well exactly I mean so whenever
a senseless act of violence occurs the
left has an inexhaustible list of
excuses for the person who went out and
blatantly committed an unjustifiable act
of violence but when someone defends
themselves well now they're evil
incarnate now we're not going to examine
the situation we're not going to give
them the luxury of analyzing every
socio-economic factor that could have
led to them being in that situation
we're not going to say they did it
because there wasn't enough funding
given to their school library and they
would have been an upstanding member of
society who never did anything wrong if
the situation had been different it's
simply that person is evil incarnate and
we have to lock them up and throw away
the key now we're very tough on crime
imagine if instead of coming out and
saying why aren't they giving mental
Health treatments to these these these
poor poor homeless men it's like okay
well he was violent what if they came
out and said why aren't they giving
proper self-defense training to our
Marines who could have done a proper
restraint that would not have harmed
this man oh there's a bunch of different
ways you can pretend to be outraged
that's right I'll tell you where my
outrage is it is the city is lacks on
crime and allows these people to roam
free they are struggling to maintain
their system at all we have leftists
saying that Rikers people die there that
people are unjustly held there and I'm
like your city is broken period your
policies don't work your politicians
don't work yet every time you Democrats
who run New York City screw up you
complain about some other this let me
let me tell you where it comes from
all of these problems we hear about the
culture were police brutality let's talk
about that they're in Democrat cities
you don't hear you know give name name
uh one of these stories and it is in a
democrat-run jurisdiction yep of course
almost almost entirely not all of them
but almost exclusively and they're
complaining is I just it's as
meaningless completely think about this
though there's two phases that they
screwed it up number one they're not
giving these guys enough training I'm
talking about the cops right now they're
not giving them the training which is
money so they're defunding they're
taking money out of the budgets of these
different law enforcement areas the
second thing is they're not backing
their play when you're a cop on the
street and I've talked to you know lots
of cops I spent a bunch of time dealing
with them in my old job they're out
there and they know they are not being
supported by the apparatus there so if
they have to use deadly force if they
have to use any justifiable Force
they're probably going to be facing
charges and there's no joy like they're
not going to be qualified immunity
they're not going to be scoped they're
not going to have defense that's paid
for by the local jurisdiction it's going
to come out of their pocket or it's
going to come out of the Union they're
going to get crushed so they are they do
the Freddie what do they call the
Ferguson effect the Freddie gray effect
they scale back and they let this thing
happen and that's how you get a crazy
man threatening to kill people on a
subway when somebody saw him I guarantee
you he went by cops this is what
community policing looks like right when
the community is doing the policing
that's what you get you get P because
and I said that on Twitter the other day
and and some leftist get got all up in
my mentions and had a problem and it's
like oh there's all these books and
that's not how it works and Etc but what
they're neglecting to address is that
when you say community policing on the
internet to the vast majority of the
population you're gonna have a
significant portion of un
unsophisticated people that are going to
hear that and they're going to think I
have to take care of myself it's my job
to help now whether or not that's the
case it doesn't matter people are going
to think that and they're going to act
like that and that's what you get that's
that's all that you get you're going to
get more of this the fewer cops you have
the fewer security or the less security
you have on the subway system the more
you're gonna get this so this is this is
100 aoc's fault this is Rashida talib's
fault this is a uh
Ayanna Presley's fault the squad they're
all guilty all of the Democrats that
have been screaming
there the mayor well no the mayor's
actually kind of good I think he was
complaining but it's the DA's fault it's
it's the vice president's fault for
bailing out people when they were
rioting in 2020 it is 100 the Democrats
fault down the line they were calling
for this the blood is on their hands and
for them to even try to blame the poor
guy that was trying to help the poor
people on the subway is absolutely
absurd and should not even be tolerated
by by reasonable people so uh
who here thinks this guy is going to be
indicted and convicted
I I say yes I think they're going to
criminally indict him and then they're
going to convict him and they're going
to get him on some charge where they're
like we understand that there was some
fear here but he went too far and just
because you're scared does not give you
the right to kill so you know next legit
there's on the side or something yeah
there's a reasonableness standard they
can indict him that's going to be that's
a no-brainer okay so we can just throw
that that's gonna happen for sure
there's demand for it so there will be a
supply for it they will make that happen
but what you do have is a lot of people
that ride the subway that can make on a
jury there's a lot of people who have
seen that situation and the question is
this are they going to believe their own
Lying Eyes and what they've seen and
experience and the fear that they've
maybe had and the internet videos
they've shared with their friends or are
they going to go with what their party
tells them they're supposed to do
because New York City is not universally
there's like 70 they're going to go with
what their party tells them to do you
know why because they're gone you only
need one juror they're going to be
escort into the courthouse by armed
police with rifles as violent Riders
scream about and scream threats at them
and then go to their homes and uh what
was it one uh what trial was it where
one of the witnesses or whatever had a
pig's head put on their porch and a
blood splattered on it but it was like
the wrong house or something like that I
don't know in Minnesota yeah
like the showman trial in Minnesota you
have armed police with rifles long guns
standing outside escorting in the jury
looking at all of the chaos and violence
the message is clear it doesn't matter
what you think is right the far left is
firebombing buildings and they will come
after you so if this guy gets indicted I
really don't see someone in New York
being like I will accept the
consequences in a city surrounded by far
left extremists
what if they were able to get the venue
outside they won't do it
look at look at Minnesota when they so
they can appeal I mean they can make
that request and the judge they'll get
denied they'll say uh there's the this
is what happened in Minnesota they said
there's no jurisdiction In Minnesota
where people don't know what happened
now my response that is then case
dismissed because the Constitution
warrants a fair trial and if you're
saying outright everyone is biased then
you cannot try this man sorry he's free
to go they didn't do that they just said
no you're gonna buy his trial and we're
gonna lock you up sorry have a nice day
I I just look there's a possibility this
guy I I hope and the other piece is it
has to be up in front and center that
this guy what he did was was appropriate
and and you know using your voice the
way you're doing it is actually really
important because otherwise this guy
gets steamroll he has no chance I do
agree with you that there's a very high
probability the other thing is Phil what
you were saying earlier you know
community policing and the nature of it
the Supreme Court has already ruled on
that by the way they've said that the
police do not owe you personally a duty
to safety so they have no duty to act on
your behalf they owe the public a duty
but that's a very nebulous concept it's
vague and it's open so individually you
can be screwed yeah so you may have to
defend yourself and uh I know you guys
had Mike Glover on here before he says
something be your own first responder
that's something I think is an
incredibly important message right now
and we're living in it in some places
you can do that and you'll be able to
survive you do it in New York City
you're probably going to go to jail
unfortunately even if it was correct
carry a gun
if you legally that's why not in New
York yeah that's what I do but I mean I
like you know where where are legally
allowed which leads us to a the larger
question of or the larger statement the
better piece of advice live in
constitutional carry states yes because
if you're in New York I mean look at
this
three people on this train thought what
this guy was doing warranted restraint
three people so if you come to me and
say what made you think it was
reasonable oh I don't but three people
did right three people had this guy down
you can't defend yourself in these
places no and look you know I I
mentioned this about New Jersey
I was told that if I was in New Jersey
in my own home and someone broke in with
the intent to kill and I shot them
they said yes you have a right to defend
yourself you'll be arrested charged with
murder you will spend time in prison you
know awaiting or or jail depending on
how just handles it and then you can
assert your affirmative defense to the
judge that it was self-defense that's
New Jersey
does is New Jersey duty to retreat
within your own home yes yeah oh my God
they call it partial castle doctrine
you're only you're only allowed to use
Force to defend your home if you have no
way out the but they they also say so I
asked them they said a window is a way
out and they gave me the gulag
archipelago response of just run away if
someone's like if your wife and children
are on the second floor you have a duty
to run out the first floor and leave
them there they expect you to leave so I
was told yes wow but it does really
depend on the judge you get there look
there is the idea that that's even up to
a judge right is insane the complete
moral insane I mean but it's not to
judge everywhere and uh even in West
Virginia there's like some
reasonableness standard to whether or
not if somebody's walking on your
property you can't get kill them you
know what I mean if someone's running
towards your home screaming with bloody
rage holding a weapon yep I'm pretty
sure in West Virginia you can West
Virginia's got some of them so West
Virginia I'm pretty sure you can defend
your physical property like your fields
and this has a lot to do with the fact
that it's a rural country where there's
a lot of acreage and people Farm whereas
in Maryland you can defend your house
only after going inside of it and the
idea is you might be out with your
family in the field doing work when
someone threatens you and you can use
Force to defend yourself in Maryland
property tends to be a lot smaller so
they say if you're outside your home and
someone is threatening you you have a
duty to go into your home if you are in
your home and they attempt to to break
into your home I believe West Virginia
I'm sorry I believe Maryland allows
these of lethal Force to prevent someone
from breaking into your home and then in
New Jersey
you better jump out that window and go
run Buck Naked through the woods you got
to do what they call the dynamic plf
going out the window the parachute
Landing fall and keep your feet and
knees together and try to make it decide
I said where do I go where do I go to my
house yeah and and and the response the
cops were like kind of based they were
like no we get it but what they'll tell
you is that you that proves You're a
murderer because you're what you're
basically saying is you you had a choice
to make between standing outside or
killing a person and you made the choice
to kill a person that is not reasonable
that's that's their view in New Jersey
well and the rest of America looks at it
and says uh you know oh you do you value
your stuff more than you value somebody
else's life it's like well they value my
stuff more than they value their own
lives obviously they came into my house
that's how it works in Texas
um when I was actually going through so
before I was a a law enforcement officer
I was a concealed carrier I carried like
everybody else and I had a permit
because Texas is very newly uh come into
this sort of constitutional carry game
and when I went through those courses
one of the things that was kind of
interesting is the guy said not only can
you defend yourself in almost any
situation that you're in you have no
duty to retreat but there is actually a
deadly force scenario where someone is
stealing your stuff in Aid of nighttime
mischief and that was the way the code
was written now this goes back to maybe
2013 or 2014. so I don't know if it's
still still stands in Texas but
legitimately if someone stole your car
stereo and was running down the street
you theoretically although I don't
recommend it could shoot them in the
back in Texas I'm pretty sure you don't
want to do that in Austin but if you did
it in like Odessa you might be okay kind
of thing like you don't want to do it in
big cities but I'm just saying like
theoretically that was on underneath the
uh the actual statutory law that was a
defense sure once again I don't care if
you steal my car stereo I'm not going to
shoot you in the back that seems
ridiculous to me yeah but if you present
an imminent danger of death or serious
physical injury while you are doing
something like that which they call
nighttime Mischief which could just be
sneaking around your property then your
standard is actually you meet the
standard so there are reasons to use
deadly force in that or even I just I
Googled it real quick and apparently the
answer is simply put yes you can but it
says it's not it's uh this this lawyer
says it's not been used effectively in
practice that checks because most people
are going to be like are you nuts well
there's a there's a standard of it too
right like that's the other thing you
find about people that carry concealed
weapons and all of you out there that do
that sort of thing know it as well
there's a standard of is it a judicious
use of your Force do you really want to
to go through whatever that experience
is because you're probably going to get
arrested if you shoot somebody in the
back running with your stereo I mean you
know if you are right yeah I mean you
know this but for for the listeners out
there the things that you need to
legitimize not legalize but to
legitimize because jurisdictions change
but you need to have uh ability
opportunity and intent right to to
someone has to have the ability to harm
you they have to have the opportunity
and they have to have the intent they
have to make it clear to you that
they're going to they have to be in the
same room and they have to have some way
to do it some of it is reasonable is too
because there's some of those things you
can't actually you can you can't look at
somebody in the dark and know what's
coming on sure I would assume that if
you come into my house at 3am and I'm
sleeping and there's a flashlight and
well and you have hands which you do
because you opened up my door yeah then
you have some negative intent because
people sleep in their houses at three
amps yeah but then you're expecting
something the point that I'm making is
just those three things have to actually
all happen for it to be a legitimate use
of force to defend your life and if you
don't have those then you don't do it so
if a guy's running away don't because
you're gonna get sick there's no upside
but there is so there actually is a
federal standard that we would always
play by and I think it actually works
well for people even outside of a law
enforcement capacity it's essentially
this it's very very simple if a person
is basically threatening imminent danger
imminent danger means right now that's
not a future action that's not like
Ashley Babbitt could have become a
problem I mean like right now there's a
problem with this person and if you're
going to say that person presents an
imminent danger of death or serious
physical injury which is a little vague
but we know that a physical injury can
happen that can be serious and some are
not so that's core stuff imminent
physical danger death or serious
physical injury to yourself or to
another person that you're responsible
for that's a deadly force scenario you
can actually go for it this is what the
Texas texas.gov sent me to it says so
when can you use deadly force in Texas
to protect property Texas law allows you
to use deadly force to protect property
if you would be justified in zinc force
and you reasonably believe it is
imminently necessary immediately
necessary to prevent the imminent
Commission of specific enumerated
property crimes these are arson burglary
robbery aggravated robbery theft during
the night time or criminal mischief
during the night time
so it does say specifically if if you
see someone trying to steal property
from you
and then you shoot them that's a serious
felony if they turn towards you that
changes everything
so it's and I also kind of think like
nighttime Mischief in general is my
favorite thing to be in criminal statute
Mischief during the night time just like
nighttime Mischief I just think that but
but you probably all got involved in
nighttime Mischief when we were kids so
that's also terrifying because I grew up
in Texas but I think I think the reason
for these laws in places like Texas is
they typically want you to be able to
defend yourself from crime but they
don't want people to randomly shoot
people so like you know I was talking to
someone in West Virginia and I said what
if someone enters my property in West
Virginia can I defend it and I think I
was talking to a cop actually he said if
someone just is walking on your land you
can't just shoot them because people
accidentally walk on land a lot however
legally
you can defend your property from
someone who is committing a crime and
enters the property so you know
basically you you need to be able to
justify why you thought they were
committing crime or something like that
despite the fact that it's kind of more
vague than you can articulate the
reasons and those reasons would be
justifiable and it's and that's very
subjective the way you articulate it
they always say this uh in government
service it's like it's not what you did
it's how you write it up yeah okay and
then the military is very familiar with
this too it's the way you get Awards and
certain commendations if you justify it
if it's articulated properly then you
can have a lot of things happen in your
favor and vice versa too somebody could
articulate that you were doing something
that was totally justifiable they can
articulate it in a bad way and then here
here's the important thing too it says
the jury must decide whether you had a
reasonable belief that deadly force was
immediately necessary to prevent a
perpetrator from fleeing yeah I wonder I
says immediately after committing a
burglary robbery aggravated robbery or
theft during the nighttime
to stop them from fleeing right that's
kind of intense so so that's Texas for
you you have to give a reasonable belief
that deadly force is necessary what if
the only weapon available to you is a
nine millimeter
then you need to upgrade your Arsenal
well no this might actually clear you
yeah if that's all you have on you and
what the question only the only use of
force you have is considered deadly and
you have no other Alternatives or
options is that considered reasonable
yeah I mean that's that's the fun and
obviously it goes to a jury too the
other piece of this is do people run
around with uh restraints do you keep
Flex cuffs with you are you keeping
shoestring restraints because that's
actually the tool that should have
happened in the New York Subway system
right because the guy did something if
you could immediately incapacitate him
and a blood choke would have been
appropriate he's out for a few seconds
you zip tie up his hands real quick and
they're already kit and you can carry
those things around with you tourniquets
might be a little bit more difficult to
secure properly yeah but it's better
than nothing I'm just saying people
don't run around with duct tape they
don't run around with flex cuffs they
don't run around with what they call
like shoestring uh handcuffs which I
used to keep in my pockets all the time
because they're really effective but if
you don't have that thing and most
people don't then you're stuck holding
this guy until the next stop you're on
the f-line until you get to the platform
I guess and that's the scary thing for
these people so you know tying it back
in there the reasonable standard is is
like what are they going to do let them
get up and be pissed I don't know if
you've ever if you've ever let somebody
up after they've had that sort of
experience they don't generally go like
yeah I'm de-escalating yeah once you
grab them that's it you're you're locked
in until the police comes like that that
guy didn't have a chance like an
opportunity or the option like if they
let him go he's all he was already
having an episode you're not going to
let the guy he's not going to be like
nah it's cool man I'm gonna chill now no
he'd have flipped out and there's no
question about it yeah and it's you
don't risk it even if even even if maybe
he wouldn't have you don't risk it
because he gets up and next thing you
know he's on someone else you know yeah
so we've talked about this before I even
mentioned it earlier on the show but
just the propensity of left Wingers to
project often what they will accuse
conservatives of who act in the defense
of themselves or others as having a
misinformed view of violence based on
watching action movies oh you only want
guns because you think you're some kind
of Action Hero oh you're only trying to
save the Damsel in Distress because you
saw it in the film in reality their
understanding of how using Force works
is entirely Hollywood based right like
they really think you can have a fight
some with somebody the way they do in a
Marvel movie or in a choreographed fight
scene where you're like just standing
apart like boxing each other and then
you get the bad guy down and then you
say stay there fella and he stays down
without getting back up I mean in real
life self-defense situations are
incredibly messy they're incredibly
messy but because people are used to
seeing these choreographed fight scenes
in Hollywood movies where the good guy
subdues the bad guy without hurting him
they think that your average person
should be able to do that Sheamus I've
seen the movies where like you know
Black Widow trips a guy and he falls on
it just doesn't get back up exactly that
there's no way they just made that up
that's not the Magic The Magic hit where
they like hit you with either like their
fist or they hit you with the gun like
they piss to whip you and then you're
out however long you need to to the
scene ends that's my other favorite
thing yeah those are almost always
either lethal if you were to actually
hit that one hit or that person's gonna
get up and they are going to be resuming
their fighting posture because oh now in
a very dangerous spot I love this like
how many movies have the Trope where
someone gets hit in the forehead with a
gun and then they wake up tied up in a
chair yes as if getting knocked out is a
thing yep so uh for people who don't
know if you that's called being put in a
coma you are comatose if someone can use
blunt force to incapacitate you to the
point where you're not conscious you've
been put in a coma and my understanding
is that if it's longer than even like 30
seconds or so it's it is expected you
have very serious brain damage from that
so when the hero then wakes up like in I
think it's like Casino Royale or
whatever all of them it's all it's
always a rifle butt stroke right to the
foreign
no what happens is they think they took
out everyone in the room and they're
like and then the guy was like oh
snapshot dad like yells something in
German and hits him with the butt one
guy in the corner yeah exactly I beg
people that that think that kind of
stuff just go to a Jiu Jitsu gym for one
evening like just go and try and roll
with someone that that just roll with
the white belts like you know I mean I'm
a white belt I don't know anything at
all but if you've never rolled Jiu Jitsu
I could probably wrap you up you know
and and you know it's like I heard it's
hard Mark Zuckerberg won uh you know
kind of somewhere right looks like he's
a bad man now he may be an email look
kind of nerdy but that that man is going
to do he has no reason not to exactly
yeah apparently he was in a match and
the ref said that he tapped out and he
didn't he got really angry or he's like
I didn't tell you nuts and then he
didn't beat the ref
and then he bought the gym yeah he
bought the gym and fired the rap snapped
his finger and then all the refs Dirty
Secrets just publicly appeared on
everyone's voice yeah they just fell out
of all the Facebook uh you know secret
messages he was sending it's dirty it is
true though 100 like somebody who has
some training versus someone who has no
training it's not even fair someone who
is a professional versus someone who has
a lot of training even not even fair so
you look at these things and uh it's
it's just it's a total lack of an
understanding of the physical reality of
the world we live in and some of that
like you say propagated by Hollywood is
also that women might be able to do that
yes because that is not happening on
that Subway that man in a state of
mental duress whatever it was that he
walked in there the Jordan Neely
character when he walks in and decides
that he's going to lose it you've seen
that video of the guy and I who posted
it maybe it was Ian miles chunk too but
uh guy walks in grabs a handful of hair
and he's dressed like chicken the woman
yeah and pulls it pulls her down to the
ground she can't go and no one stands up
you know what makes me the most
frustrated about that entire thing like
it makes me Furious is that the guy
who's filming it is like a pretty built
male looking masculine dude and he's
holding his phone doing the bystander
thing he'll go to jail
he'll go to jail Woody yes yeah look
what's happening with Daniel with that
with this guy Penny you know what I'd
rather go to jail I'm sorry I agree like
my Honor's not worth that it's it's not
worth it that I walk and go I let a
woman get dragged off and terrorized and
then she's going to think that every
single day of her life and yeah but she
voted for it
that bothers me just as a Christian
person I can't hold people accountable I
can't say on YouTube the answer that I
feel good about so listen listen if the
overwhelming majority of people in
places like Chicago La New York keep
voting for the same people over and over
again I actually think it is
it is a fascist of you to to imply that
your will be done and that their
Democratic vote be ignored so here's the
question so if they want to have another
did they have another option is the
other question because I've had this I I
tend to feel the same way you do on an
emotional level and I had someone
challenge me intellectually and this is
what they said they said was there a
viable alternative was there even an
alternative on the ballot in let's say
Chicago because no Republican ran not
that I think the Republican party is the
solution to anything at all uh based on
my personal experience so far but you
look at it and you go was there a was
there anyone else that could have voted
for and in Chicago whose fault is it
Paul vallis he was the right wing he he
was he was a moderate Democrat tough on
crime okay and they elected the far left
critical race Theory a socialist guy
what percentage did uh what is the name
Paul Valance valves what did he I think
it was fairly close I I think it was
only a few points for for um bro was it
Brandon Johnson's name I'm not
completely sure 100 with you because
Chicago politics are basically not
relevant Democrats have run the city for
100 years not going anywhere but the end
of the day do you hold the people that
voted for the other a guy is it their
fault too because that's the tough part
I don't know I just you do yeah I do
okay like tell me more after a hundred
years of the same thing it's like you're
holding your hand on the electric stove
going like man this shirt does suck but
I'll just keep staying here I just love
the smell of burnt flesh I'll just stay
right here I left I got out of Chicago
yeah I'd been shot at before uh I'm me
and my brother are driving down uh we're
driving off of uh 290 and Independence
and for no reason a guy just points a
gun at our car and Fires at us that's
Chicago and So eventually I'm just like
you know like I kind of don't want to be
here it it feels like a nowhere town I
would tell my friends it's the suburb of
the country it's a big city but it's
culturally stagnant it's extremely
violent and nothing is changing about it
so I'm done I'm leaving I can get behind
that yeah like I say I just want the
question asked is there any way that
these people could not be culpable and
if the answer is no then the answer is
culpable is a strong word I would put it
this way I get messages from people and
they're like Tim I really need your help
you know we need to raise money for this
guy who's being unjustly targeted or
whatever and I'm like where did it
happen oh it happened in Chicago
pass are you kidding dude come on man
like two years ago I said I know it's
hard but you got to leave these cities
and the way I describe it is people will
tell me it's really hard to do you want
to do you want me to tell you about how
I got out of Chicago I sold all my stuff
I had 400 bucks in cash I found a ride
share on Craigslist and said I will draw
he had two cars I said I'll drive one of
them behind you to San Diego that was it
and then look I'm I was like 22 or 23 at
the time whatever it's still a move and
a lot of people won't do it not like I
knew that La you know was how bad it was
going to be or whatever and uh
moderately bad but there's enough of La
is big enough to where I got by just
fine and actually found more success but
I'm like I'm not gonna stay here this
place sucks there's so many problems it
was so corrupt the cops were corrupt the
government was corrupt the crime was
rampant so I literally I was actually
intending on riding a moped I'm like I
will just be honest and I and again
people say like I have families I can't
do it so let me put it this way you are
sitting in a house and the garage is on
fire
is attached to rush
we see it happening oh your neighbor was
in the garage and he's screaming right
now and you're like yeah but I'm in the
living room and if and if and if I have
to go outside it's cold and I have kids
my kids can't be cold and it's like dude
your house is on fire if you stay inside
of it
you will lose your life it will get bad
if you leave your house now you will
survive and it will be very difficult so
the response I get for most people is
you don't know how hard it is and I'm
like Perhaps Perhaps Perhaps but doesn't
change the fact statement that staying
in places like Chicago New York or again
a Portland for instance like come on
it's a no-go yeah it looks like he's
crazy how bad it is that and it's it may
be the hardest thing you've ever done
but I just there's not a whole lot I can
say to the fifth sixth person who's like
you know oh no this guy broke into my
house and I need to raise money my mom
was hurt and I'm just like
come on man no well here's the thing you
say it's hard and it is hard but I'm 41
I got three kids I sold my house because
it was the right thing to do I left a
state that we were comfortable and we
had a palace we were on like two acres
it was awesome I had Mountain views that
like most people would stab for and we
we left because you can do it and we
moved into two bedrooms that were my
folks place that I didn't own which is
super embarrassing at 41 years old
nobody wants to go do that but at the
end of the day can you go do this yes is
it difficult sure but you still got to
do the right thing I agree with you they
should be moving I don't think there's
any saving a lot of these places I've
been to West Baltimore I see what it
gets to eventually West Baltimore looks
like there was a zombie invasion and we
lost and it's still going and it's still
there there's people that live there
it's crazy they're sections of Chicago
very much the same and it's and it's and
it's
it's kind of sad there's tremendous
opportunity in these they're massive
buildings on the south side of Chicago
completely abandoned yep and I'm just
thinking to myself can you just there's
tons of young people who want to do
things but there are these barriers as
bureaucracy but aside from that
you're talking about cities like Los
Angeles that had a Democrat super
majority and still couldn't solve the
homeless problem because they don't want
to solve the homeless problem because
they don't want to deal with any of the
issues they just want to give you
mindless self-indulgence and then
they'll take it and then crime runs
rampant and then they blame
conservatives they blame everyone else
well you look they always build they
always build like uh infrastructure
behind it they always build bureaucratic
systems that pay more of their buddies
to have a job but none of the jobs go to
like getting homeless people they get
more homeless people so putting money
into the problem makes more problem it's
it's this classic do you ever see the
demotivators you know no uh the
demotivism there was a whole thing in
the 90s of like motivational posters and
they'd have like a picture like hang in
there you can do it or whatever yeah so
I used to have one on my screen which
I'm sure was uh fantastic for on a
government screen and it used to have a
picture of the US Capitol building and
it said government
um if you if you don't if you what do
they say it says uh if you don't like
our problems you should see our
Solutions
which is a which is a winner and it's
100 accurate but like that's kind of the
attitude like government creates these
things there's another one that was
about consultants and said Consultants
something to the effect of if you're not
going to be part of the solution there's
a ton of money in continuing the problem
and that is Los Angeles like that's the
homeless situation in Los Angeles they
are continuing the problem for profit
you can always move Florida you could
well I just want to so that cities there
make a note or make a comment uh on the
the question of like bureaucracies
especially in the Chicago area so I was
also born and raised in Cook County and
I have a number of horror stories just
from people working within the various
government systems there someone I knew
insisted that when they first started a
job working for Cook County I won't say
what they did
they were working very hard
and they were getting ahead uh on their
well because it's also anecdotal right
but according to them they were getting
ahead on their work and during their
first week there and their co-workers
basically surrounded them and said we
don't do that much in a week that sounds
correct yeah we we don't we're just
letting you know like no that is a
classic government experience yeah at
all levels of government yeah what
happens if you like just say cool I'm
still gonna do it and then just make
everyone look really disciplinary action
yeah
throw you under the bus they've got
something something will come up look
you did your TPS report wasn't filed
correctly so look the other thing about
doing it I thought the government wasn't
garbage if you do a lot of work right
you now have more opportunities for them
to find procedural errors in your work
and so instead of people doing their job
they will spend every single minute of
their time to crush you because you are
upstanding the status quo just abolish
the whole thing and so bad get rid of
the whole damn thing it's it's the worst
solution to anything except when it's
the only one I think what's gonna happen
is
we're gonna hear more and more of these
stories someone's going to be like oh my
house was set on fire during the riots
what do I do it's like well should have
sold it a year ago that's right should
have sold it two years ago it's I don't
know because when it you know two three
years ago the Summer of Love three years
ago isn't that crazy and it's like well
what am I going to do there's these
riots going on it's like I get it this
sucks it's hard now it's been three
years if you have not taken the first
step towards getting away from these
cities in three years I don't know what
you expect anyone else to do for you no
matter how hard you think it is there
comes a point where it's just like
everybody left dude people went to Texas
down to Florida they went to the middle
of nowhere some people of West Virginia
and now you're gonna look around as as
antifa runs rampant and sets fire to
your institutions and shuts down your
infrastructure and then you're gonna bet
can someone please help me and there's
not gonna be anybody there yeah I I just
I don't think it's wise to bet on there
will be no more riots in these neighbors
we're one outrage away from whatever the
next trigger is right because it's not
about the it's not about the underlying
incident it's about the activity of
upsetting the the Apple car that some of
these people are just professional you
know pretty Wells I there's part of me
that thinks that there might not be
riots and before the election because
riots before the election make the
existing Administration look bad now I'm
not saying that it can't happen or
whatever I'm not making a prediction but
there's part of me that thinks it
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense for
the left to Riot and upset people the
your average noise
also like Riders are not political
strategists right no but their idea will
try to spin it any which way and I think
you're right that certain conditions can
be created for a right to flourish like
political leaders not cracking down on
them as they spring up so I hear what
you're saying there but it's possible
things just pop off they can't do
anything about it and they try to spin
it to sound like these riots are fiery
but mostly peaceful protests or whatever
label they want to throw on it see I'm
of the opinion that the right that the
riots were not organic I'm of the
opinion that they were they were people
were communicating with each other
letting other people that other leftist
there was antifa that were you know the
rioters and stuff the antifa network the
people that are in antifa they know each
other they communicate and so
and they're in in touch with like other
activists that are not rioters that are
people that'll you know they're in touch
with teachers at schools in in colleges
and stuff people that are fairly
intelligent people that can strategize
so I do think that and again I'm not
saying that I'm not making a prediction
but I do think that I wouldn't be
surprised if we don't see any kind of
significant rioting regardless of what
happens in the in the country just
because it will make it more difficult
for the left to win a for the Democrat
to win I just want to make one more
Point that's an interesting point that
could that could be accurate you could
be right about that but even so the
framing you have is
until it's convenient for there to be
more of course and so you don't want to
live in that neighborhood either way 100
100 yes I don't want to I don't I don't
want to cut down anyone's idea about
getting out of it turns right get out of
the Cities if you can I want to jump to
this story from the Daily Mail shocking
moment Tennessee High School student
pepper sprays teacher twice after he
confiscated her phone in class and
there's a lot here some people associate
this with the the increase in crime
recklessness the uh the the collapse of
authority in our institutions and I
thought it was interesting because we're
talking about whether or not this woman
was justified in pepper spraying this
soy boy teacher who collapsed and falls
to his knees after getting pepper spray
for taking their phone and I just find
the whole thing interesting the first
point is just yo our schools are messed
up yeah don't don't have your kids in
these schools and the second thing is to
what degree should we entertain the
authority of these of these teachers
but let's just start with this a
Tennessee High School teacher pepper
sprayed twice by a student assault took
place at Antioch High School outside of
Nashville reports indicate the teacher
had taken the student's phone and I'm
pretty sure she says in the video give
me back my phone so what do you guys
think yeah
well I think I mean it's a microcosm for
all the things that are wrong right so
we have one we have an absence of
masculinity because I had teachers that
if you took something if you took
something from you that was going to be
your problem right it didn't matter if
you had pepper spray I I had a I had a
guy that was in my high school who was
our disciplinarian he literally like
held a guy up by his throat against the
wall should you do that no I was a
private school so we could get away with
certain things and people wanted that of
their kids because he stepped out of
line so he had the physical ability to
dominate and this guy gets dominated by
a chick with a with a pepper spray
that's not a good not a good look but
you made an interesting point and I
agree with it people have a lot of
personal information on their phones
he's an agent of the government that's
the thing that I hadn't thought of so is
he is he representing a an unlawful
search and seizure there under the
Fourth Amendment even because there's
some interesting he's representing
certain authorities in power as a member
of a of a government is the government
before the show when we were pulling up
these stories I said this would be
really interesting to talk about because
I got to tell you if I was in a school
and someone I don't care who teacher
otherwise tried taking my iPhone you be
prepared for me to physically defend
myself there there was no circumstance
for me in in you know after a certain
age I suppose where a teacher would ever
get away with anything like that yeah
man I'm like I'm 13 years old if they
try taking my Pokemon from me I'd be
like I'll leave the building before you
touch my property so we're talking about
a cell phone this teacher this is a
common Trope like the teacher takes the
phone away you're not touching my phone
I got private messages in there you got
you got messages with with your parents
in there and the teacher's like I'm
gonna take that from you ain't touching
it I will leave before I let you do that
when he grabbed her phone from her
that's theft that's seizure by the you
we point out the government uh I hadn't
thought about it until we were literally
in the moment here yeah there is some
interesting implications about that and
I do think that the correct answer is
send her out of the room look you're
being a distraction you've been removed
from the classroom I'm done with you go
deal with the administration that's
their job then you go back to teaching
that's probably the right move so we've
got a couple of mistakes like right
we're we're like five stops down from
where things shouldn't have happened has
this always been the case that teachers
would take something from the students I
think it depends on so there are certain
places especially private schools where
you sign away you know your parents your
minders your your um the people that are
the authority your power of attorney are
going to say that they have certain
authorities to do certain things like
that and you know when I was a kid like
we didn't have that like there was no my
cell phone that I had which I think I
got when I was 17 was attached to a car
and the only way you were bringing it is
if you were bringing the whole thing in
it came out of the console so that
wasn't a real possibility and that was I
was an outlier most people didn't have
that that capability uh that being said
I don't think you should get pepper
sprayed and hit your knees with your
back to your enemy and cover yourself
and cry like a woman that that is very
offensive to me as a dude I just I just
it's troubling to watch someone go do
that kind of action it's like hey man
you lost your man card too not only did
you lose to a chick but you lost your
man card and now no one's gonna look at
you again yeah a cop should just I mean
the the uh teacher should have just
kicked her out let her keep her phone
get out of here yep leave I mean it's
probably gonna be kicking her out every
day and you're gonna end up kicking her
out of school because she's probably not
going to listen tomorrow she'll be back
she didn't look like like she could take
Direction no based on her her
interactions but also as you mentioned I
don't know what's you mentioned the
possibility that we're talking about
someone probably 16 to 18 based on the
high school right and she was an older
high school student
um she's got private photos she may have
private photos which we could uh we
don't have to discuss the nature of but
probably would be actually a crime to
possess uh if you're a dude so that's
not something you want to get it's just
like these bad actions but it's also
funny when like she pepper sprays him
and he just falls to his knees it hurts
me it hurts my masculinity like I don't
want him to go chop wood like he needs
to grow up beer he has a beard too
doesn't he
yeah he said there you go watch he's
like running from her yes he needs to
shave his face immediately and she's
like papilla be just like walking
casually oh did they skip the part where
he falls to his knees no it's coming at
the end she sprays what is what is he
doing this is look at this there she
gets him oh down surrender fail turns
his back what is hey it's like maintain
control of the phone that's the only
upside to this guy is that he held onto
the property so he won that minor minor
Victory while losing his man card that's
wild yeah and people around him are like
I just got pepper spray too you know the
thing about pepper spray it's a very
imprecise uh defensive weapon it sprays
all over it is the worst in fact I
remember going through the academy and
everybody has to get sprayed with it but
the one thing they said is like here's
your pepper spray now put it somewhere
where you'll never use it because it's
awful if you ever use it like when you
see a guy like on a search warrant if
you're trying to subdue a subject and
they're like I got this I'm gonna nobody
wants that happening it's everybody
everybody Burns everything it sucks
people think it's like it gets in your
mucus membranes it burns on your skin
you're irritated you're like I remember
taking a shower afterwards and my neck
was burning yeah like this is terrible
but yeah when we were in uh we're at the
j17 riots was it J no no J 20th uh riots
in 2017 when Trump was getting
inaugurated I was there too and we were
you know me and Luke are like drenched
in pepper spray God you go take a shower
afterwards and just burns it just
reactivates yeah it just reactivates
it's burning all over 100 I don't know
man I saw this story I thought it was
yeah this is way worse by the way what
is it yes yeah the the tear gas is
Wayward for me when we were in uh
Ferguson the police were using CS smoke
so they called it yeah tear gas and so
that's the stuff that fogs and kind of
lingers down there on you and uh and CNN
reported there was no tear gas being
fired it was just smoke
and uh it's because these are evil
people I'm pretty sure it was Don Lemon
so Ryan Riley was the guy who saw the
ear plugs that's right and thought they
were rubber bullets that's right he's
probably watching he's one of my biggest
fans we were uh uh I'm on the ground and
we are gagging in tear gas and I I
started to pass out because I got into a
cloud of it and tunnel vision starts
forming it's a choking agent right it's
it's displacing the oxygen in my lungs
and then I fall down and I got lucky
some kids splashed water on my face it's
crazy craziest thing I I have no idea so
um I'm in Ferguson tear gas everywhere
gunshots go off cops are like go go run
so I'm I'm running and I'm and I walk
through a cloud of tear gas inhale it
all and then all of a sudden I'm like I
can't I can't breathe I'm like it's just
my lungs aren't working and then I'm
like
and then I get tunnel vision where
everything starts turning black to a
point and then I just fall down the
grass on my back and the next thing I
know some kids splashes water my face
and I go
and I should have done that oh I don't
know how that kid knew
or maybe it was just fortunate yeah it
just gave us splashing splashing water
triggers the uh the inhale reflex or
whatever what's crazy is we used to call
that meeting the wizard meeting the
wizard yeah so you've seen The Wizard of
Oz right oh my God what people don't
realize is that when you start getting
hypoxic like that and I've been there
too many times in a very chaotic way but
what happens is you lose color vision
first you don't know it it's very
Insidious hypoxia is an Insidious yeah
move so you lose the color vision and
then like you said you get that Bugs
Bunny at the end of the Looney Tunes
where it starts tightening down it's all
folks yeah and you're looking you're
looking through the loot through the
tunnel right and then that goes out and
what other people don't realize too is
when you do that in slow motion
especially if you're underwater the last
thing to go is is your auditory nerves
different nerves so you'll actually stop
being able to see but you'll still hear
so you can feel things around you you
can hear things around you but you can't
see anything and then you go out we call
that meeting the wizard because because
that's when you go to Oz right uh and
then when you wake back up like
obviously like you had the kid Splash
you thank God and then you get that that
uh you know uh recovery and you pop up
and then everything kind of comes back
out once and you get you get the color
vision so that's kind of going to Oz
it's it's I don't know it's a phenomenon
that very few people can can relate to
if they haven't ever you can't fake it
you can only experience oh for sure and
I I wonder what would have happened to
me if that kid didn't wasn't happening
it was standing with a bottle of water
and he just poured it on my face and I'm
like like it was the craziest thing and
I'm like whoa and I was like boom back
everything was normal again yeah goofy
enough you've probably got about two
three minutes worth of uh sitting there
stagnant without breathing even and
you're still okay but it can get bad
fast and and that's why tear gas is one
of those things where it's an area
avoidance tool you can pivot to what
happened to January 6. they were
releasing the stuff and it was just
going everywhere and they were lobbing
it into the crowd and then they were
forcing the crowd into the barriers
right so it's that just tells me that
those people don't know how to use that
particular tool which is not their fault
they probably weren't trying on it you
spray it where you don't want people to
be which is usually where you are and
then you put your mask on and then it's
an area denial as opposed to putting it
into people and making them run like you
did people don't understand too when I
was in Turkey
the police fired it into a tunnel and
the people just collapsed it's yeah like
there's no air anymore and they just
started falling down and then people
were like someone's got you gotta run in
there and drag them out don't breathe
yeah the the so the crazy thing too is
people don't realize that the stuff they
use in the US is nothing the stuff that
we have rules here yeah in Brazil I was
like ah tear gas saying nothing and I'm
like oh I'm like mucus is just pouring
out of every orb that is my experience
yeah full on what they do for everybody
who goes through basic training so
anybody who's done military training has
seen this they don't do it the same way
for for cops as far as I know but some
guys get it but you go into like a
chamber and then they fill the chamber
up with smoke and you've got your mask
on and you're like this looks like a
really bad place to take off a mask and
then they tell you to take it off and
then you have to say a paragraph of some
kind usually it's a you know a rote
memory thing and you're going like and
you just have no ability to put any
you're like and you have to get out the
paragraph or they won't let you out so
the worst you know you're just kind of
fun though it's yes
Adrenaline Rush after you come out is
insane so when I would rather been in
because I have everything empty out of
my eyes my ears my nose yeah I'm like
vomiting right now it's horrible when I
went in there when I was in they they
make you take your mask off and you have
to wait for everyone in the room to get
the mask off before you can put it on to
clear it then you take it off again and
then you say whatever it is then you put
it on again and clear it then they let
you out so you're standing there holding
the mask in front of your waiting for
all the idiots that don't that lick
windows and you know and you can then
you can hear the guy just go he's like
we're waiting on everyone we're waiting
on and you're sitting there dying
wanting to kill the person right so yeah
it but when you when you come out the
adrenaline and stuff after you survive
you're walking out and you feel like you
accomplished it's great you know the gas
that's used in Turkey was not as strong
as Brazil but it was so intense that the
mass we had didn't work at all I like
that you're a connoisseur of Cs gases oh
that's not a thing that everybody has in
their repertoire you can tell you about
the flavor profile yes I think there's a
fine bouquet with a hint of all of it he
spits it back out clears his palette
with some water and spray it again
you're actually supposed to swallow it
you're you know like it's like tasting
one number one remember when Homer
became a mall cop and he pepper sprayed
his eggs
that's how it goes so one of the one of
the things I remember when I was in
Portland I went into one of the places
this is off duty so we're just like you
know we went to Whole Foods and got some
food we went to a you know Pub and stuff
like that and me and my buddies are
walking through and at some point we
went through some Park and there's all
the metal railings as you know as the Cs
dissipates it doesn't go away it just
comes out of the air and it settles so
you'll see it like on on railings and
every once in a while somebody will
touch the railing where the Cs was and
it activates where they'll get some of
the pepper spray and it activates on a
hand and so I just remember one of my
buddies was like in front of me going
down these stairs and then he reached
his hand up he goes don't touch that
rail and we're like what and he's like
it's spicy like you couldn't come up
with anything else but it was legit
spicy you watch him his hand is over
there and you go like oh yeah I don't
want this you can put on your eggs you
get your man card back if you if you
drop to your knees in a high school
after stealing a girl's phone and you
cry like a girl I think you get your man
card back if you put it on your eggs
like for like a week dude I remember
when I was like I want to spend 12 or 13
and I was in my buddy's garage and he
had some pepper spray I was like what is
this and I just like sprayed it it was
it was horrible
exactly I didn't get the full effect of
like having it directly sprayed my face
but it was not a fun experience I was
like okay now I understand why this is
used as a deterrent yeah yeah you don't
want yeah I didn't like that pepper
balls are I think relatively common now
in right control stuff and I've I've
been hit in the face with a pepper ball
Ricochet so when I was in Baltimore I
was the I think it was the Freddie gray
riots the cop for no reason me and two
other people clearly with cameras
filming he fired at something I think it
was aiming for my face but it hit
something to my left like the wall and
then sprayed plastic bits and and pepper
all into my face and I'm like did you
have glasses on no you knew now though
eye protection very quick well normally
like even in my old YouTube pictures
like with the goggles yeah and I'm like
on a roof in New York but you don't know
when to put the goggles on and it sucks
to put them on the whole time exactly
and then also wear the gas masks on her
neck and the goggles and it's just like
you want to try to avoid using them
because you want to maximize your
sensory you know for sure you know well
that's the other thing most people have
those things and you see I saw antifa
guys in Portland and I don't know maybe
gals or maybe neither whatever they
wanted to identify us and they have all
that equipment but a lot of them if you
don't train in that stuff if you don't
spend time in it you're you're lost
because the second like imagine if
somebody just suddenly just gave you
just like a tube to look through and
you're like here's your new world yeah
and by the way you can't hear anything
which changes your balance it changes
your jaunt like the way you step the way
you identify cuts out your peripheral
vision you don't know who's standing
gear left your right it gets real
dangerous they have those full face
masks where it's a sheet of plastic
basically over your face and those are
better but you still have barriers on
your left and your right so it's you
know looking through like you said like
a tunnel yeah well you imagine the guys
that are running out there with night
vision you're a security guy always tell
me about what was like oh I got to
invest and it's like it's a you got to
spend time now you've got to go for
walks with night vision on just in your
neighborhood you look like a psychopath
but you got to do it I've got some
nighttime Mischief so you might be
involved in nighttime Mischief as long
as you stay on the road right Tim yeah
I've got the super the really expensive
ones so like the Panos are they the no
but uh very expensive they're like 10
grand and they they sit right here and
you can't see around
they're you know they're awesome look up
at the sky you can see satellites yeah
it could be a spiritual experience for
people yeah it's looking at the sky
through night vision is that's what I
did with my mother-in-law I actually
shared it with my mother-in-law changed
her she was like this is incredible this
is worth the price yeah you could see
everything it's crazy get IR flashlights
for your guns now yeah so you put the IR
flashlights on right right and then when
you turn the light on only you can see
the light it's pitch black for everybody
else you know you can see the light the
laser in there then you're set to goons
out that's right
I want to jump to this story here about
Michael Knowles we got this the story
from timcast.com transheiser Bush
Michael Knowles details Bud Light parent
companies ties to w e f saying they're
mired in World economic Forum ESG gobble
deep
he says the trans-hiser Bush is still
scrambling over the Mulvaney beer can as
sales continue to tank but it's caught
between a rock of customers and a hard
place called g-a-r-m A World economic
Forum backed operation which was
subpoenaed Friday by Jim Jordan in the
house Judiciary here's why one might
think that Bud Light could just
apologize men aren't women but no matter
how much Bud Light impairment company a
b inbev might wish to reign in the
radicalism they can't abandon the agenda
they're mired in World economic Forum
ESG gobbledygook he says
Budweiser claims to be a beer rooted in
the heart of America but in 2008 the
Belgian company inbev bought a uh bought
a B for 52 billion dollars putting a
fixture of American culture into a
European rival's hands for the New York
Times now it's beholden to the elite the
world economic Forum un and EU
Bud light's suggestion the Dylan
Mulvaney endorsement was just some
one-time thing would be more believable
if Abe and Bev didn't openly admit to
wanting to ensure their pro-trans
diversity touched upon all functions
including marketing
he says a B inbev has embraced a Litany
of woke initiatives from ESG to Dei
along with full endorsement of
transgenderism they now foot the bill
when employees choose to mutilate their
bodies so I believe I want to get the
precise language from uh he would say
say we have introduced inclusive
benefits such as gender affirming
medical support for transgender
colleagues in the US and Canada and
financial and legal support for name
changes for colleagues in Brazil and
Colombia so when they say it was just
one can and it was a rogue third-party
marketing let me tell you what they're
really saying first it's not second boy
are they scared they are lying and
trying to pass the buck off in
desperation because 26 drop in sales by
the end of I think it was April what is
it April 15th so we don't even have the
sales data for the for the last the week
after that the week after that we're
nearly two and a half weeks since those
numbers came out how much you want to
bet it's worse it's becoming a cultural
phenomenon and they are reeling from it
I don't think that I mean the the idea
that that having this gender bending of
of the population popularization of the
LGBT community community that is popular
with a certain segment of the population
but yeah it's a small segment and it
tends to be younger people but to think
that that's going to work with you know
even Millennials definitely not Gen X
not Boomers and Millennials probably
it's still small you you get maybe the
Zoomers but that's about it and so like
Tim had mentioned before uh it boils
down to advertising to kids and your
average person is just like I don't want
to think about that stuff when I'm
hanging out with my buddies drinking
beer I don't want to think about your
political stuff and that's really what
it is it's shoehorning sexual politics
or the politics of sexuality into
everyday life and most people just want
to live their lives and hang out with
their friends why take that shot like
why nobody wants it it's not popular
they think there are too many people
simple as that yes so they're creating a
culture around people having less
children
and I'm fighting that one child at a
time yeah you got it you got it I'm
fighting it right now actively
you start with one thing for every kid
they don't have you have two that's it I
used to say the same thing about meat
when people would say I'm not going to
eat meat because it's cruel it's like
for every cow you don't need I'm gonna
eat too that gets really really hard to
do I could do it with maybe like one
steak at a time I've done it just gotta
order twice as many ounces that's it you
say is that person over there vegan I'll
get an extra steak send me the 22 ounces
you have to stop meeting vegans too
because eventually you're going to be
eating so many extra cows it's gonna be
too much you're gonna become just let
you eat all kinds
I had a sergeant I worked with and he
would always look at people and he was
like you know you are what you eat and
we're like and he was like to become a
tank you must eat a tank and I was like
what are you talking about you you'd
always eat like this like you would
shovel things in four like like 90
degrees to the space it's like I know
that's right I worked but uh but then
when someone starts meatheading like
that they start doing it more and more
they start becoming the tank the more
you eat the meat the more Beefcake you
have to become obviously you know I
watch those videos from fleckis talks
and uh those YouTubers that go to Times
Square and ask questions like name a
country that starts with the letter U
and they're like Utah and you're just
like oh yeah how many how many things
are how many things are in a dozen and
then someone and then the host will just
be like how about the United States of
America and they go oh and it's just
like you have to imagine that Klaus
Schwab is watching those videos too and
he's like don't you get it this is why
I'm doing what I am doing like eliminate
the people there yeah they're they're
malthusian
they they think there's too many people
and so they quite literally want there
to be less of them and
that's a fact does that coincide with AI
to be able to do the grunt work because
someone's going to still have to do all
the stupid things yes
it is a fact that Global Elites think
there's too many people Bill Gates talks
about it all the time sure it is also a
fact there is a culture being built
around people not having kids
sterilizing their kids or sterilizing
themselves whether or not those two
things are related it's up to you to
decide that's fair did you ever read
Rainbow Six the original Tom Clancy book
you've seen the game obviously yeah yeah
the book itself and this goes back
somebody about to say how long it goes
back maybe they'll tell you in the chat
like what year it was written but it
goes back and it talks about these
Global Elites who want to get rid of all
these people they set up a utopian set
of preserves they bought up all this
land with a ton of money and then they
decide to kill everybody with a super
virus and they almost get away with it
except uh Tom Clancy's rainbow six guys
go kill everybody which is fantastic but
the fact of the matter is this idea has
been propagated for a long time even in
pop culture have you played uh the
division I haven't played very many
games in a while the division is a
plague basically wipes out sure the
planet and then the government activates
Presidential Directive 51 creating a
continuity of government and then you're
the division to go in and try and
restore functions and you're like in New
York in the apocalypse yeah that sounds
like that sounds and they talk about it
sounds prophetic at this point right
talk about operation dark winter I think
it was called
wasn't that uh one of the actual things
that was going on these all these coded
reveals the massive war game about a
pandemic wiping out the planet or
something like that yeah I think we saw
a very light version in 2020. the only
upside that I ever see about 2020 which
which is minimal because a lot of people
lost a lot of freedom uh a lot of
careers were destroyed a lot of families
uh you know had a lot of Discord and
stuff like that the only thing that I
saw that was good was essentially that
the the ball got moved the goal posters
were moved while people were watching in
real time and they did 10 years worth of
a jump in a few months and everyone was
like oh what are they doing like look at
that look I see it I see them doing it
they saw the game and so some people not
everybody obviously but a lot of people
were able to see that the game has
changed and now they're on to it so it's
a lot harder to pull that stuff off and
they were doing it as a dry run but they
revealed their hand they dropped the
veil and people saw it there's a a
mutual of mine on Twitter he's a New
Hampshire uh
um legislator his name's Mike Belcher
he's at Mike Belcher 14 and he's got
this great uh theory that Alex Jones can
actually see the future but he can only
see the future when he's looking through
a potato so it's like this crazy weird
way to explain the future but it still
kind of pans out where Alex Jones is
kind of right is it possible that he's
from the future because some of the
things he said to me you know through he
didn't say it to me personally he
doesn't speak in my head although I
would take that that would be fun but
but I look at it and I go like I could
never even have come up with that idea
his thought experiments especially about
like time travel and Aliens I go like
that's probably the most plausible thing
I've ever heard it's possible while he
was high hammered it's possible but I
really do like the idea of like Alex
Jones kind of like searing into a potato
yeah divining yeah like dividing the
future exactly like it's the crystal
ball some kind of Irish fortune teller
you see that was you who did that
Sheamus no I don't believe in magic I
didn't say anything about potatoes
that's fair that's right you're that's
fair I did make that it could have been
a prophecy yeah exactly that's also true
there are many gifts but one Spirit
right amen what's an Irish witch called
uh I guess a druid
really my buddy would call anybody who
wear a who wears a hoodie a druid he
would yell that at them he's from New
York whenever you see people walking
with their Hood down and they would
upset him he'd be like what are you
doing you drew it and people like I was
like that's a very sophisticated you
know sort of insult I'm not 100 sure
they're not associated with that kind of
magic are they uh I'm pretty sure yeah
I'm pretty sure you know that was all
Druids right yeah but I thought that was
more like they came there astrology well
the people who built it but I think the
story was The Druids kind of adopted it
and started doing their own kind of
thing because they're like look at these
cool Stones like a Seer we don't have to
put anything up a fortune teller a witch
I don't know if Druids are like looking
into into the future well I got news for
you none of them are actually looking
into the future but I don't know if I I
don't know the Irish ones yeah the Irish
I mean what about Alex Jones you're
debunking the whole Irish had the gift
of foresight you know the world might
look a little bit different
that's so true
it's like like an 11 layer sort of uh
evaluation in one sentence I don't know
yeah Sheamus always tells me that I'm
racist for bringing up these Irish jokes
and here he is he's just going off
people I'm allowed to though you're
Irish too
no remember when Lance told you what
your ethnicity is
yeah when he said that although I'm not
white I'm white exactly so I'm telling
you although you're Irish you're not but
it's okay because I'm a plastic Patty
too I was born here don't you I've said
this before dude Irish people will be
like ah how can you say you're Irish
when you were born in America it's like
dude I'm not bragging it's an admission
people should know all right ethnically
where are my ancestors from I think I
owe them that dude I'm not bragging
uh we have a bunch of other stories too
that I wanna like did you just have
Cloud Schwab looking over this this
whole meeting and this discussion and
he's just looking down with disgusting
disapproving just an awful guy he just
looks like a bond villain I feel like
they're not trying that hard when they
cast him they're like who could we get
to look exactly like he dresses like a
bond villain yeah because he is a bond
villain he's a legitimate real-life Bond
villain so I guess we can wrap this one
up by just saying uh don't buy
Anheuser-Busch products and we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show going live
at about 10 10 p.m on the front page of
timcast.com for all you to watch and see
and I want to talk about Jake Shields
challenging trans men to a fight but
we'll save that one for the UN for the
members only not so family friendly uh
uncensored show but uh let's uh let's
read those super chats all right
good peasant says damn can't believe
I've been a member this long I don't
don't always agree with you Tim because
I can make up my mind but I appreciate
your commentary
chaotic good peasant member 35 months
wow that's a very very long time I can't
believe we've been doing this job this
long
it's crazy
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I was up
in the Poconos this weekend went to a
local bar bartender asked what I wanted
said definitely not a Bud Light the
logos are on the bar laughed she said
you're you're not the only one
a lot of kegs going just sitting there I
was I've been making those jokes the
past few weekends too and everyone
laughs when I mention Bud Light like you
know someone will be back you want to
get a drink oh Bud Light huh then
everyone just laughs and then the guy's
like I'll be Yingling yeah some people
have people would rather have a smearing
off ice yeah I would rather get iced
than than have a book do they still have
Bacardi O3 is that still a thing I don't
know Bartles
well that's have you ever seen that like
the the meme where they have the uh it's
like the uh the thing from
the mystery buying what is that called
Scooby-Doo they do the Scooby-Doo meme
where they unzip the uh the the Smirnoff
Ice and it's actually just it's zema
yeah
it's the same thing they just changed
the label
Alex says so we just going to ignore
murderers who watch leftist content
who's killed people and watched The View
The Young Turks Chris Cuomo delicious of
course yeah but see the thing is we
don't got to play their Narrative of
course they're going to make up stupid
garbage nonsense I don't care whatever
they're a cult it's like you know it's
like if a bunch of cultists knocked on
your door and told you the moon was made
of cheese and they needed money from you
are you gonna be like well I really
don't want to be embarrassed in front of
the Moon cultists you're gonna get get
out of here and you're gonna wiggle a
broom at him I got my porch you're crazy
moon people you're only saying that
because Moon Lord's not on tonight why
if he was here he'd defend himself well
to be fair too um they're already
watching The View like what else are you
gonna be able to do to them never no one
should never worry about what Heaven's
Gate thinks of them they were very they
were very orderly I lived in San Diego
when that went down really and it was
very ordering you don't have to worry
about what Scientology thinks about you
except for their legal department you
know because you have the right Nikes
yeah so
they have purple capes Amanda dilt says
Tim I use some of your videos where
guests are talking about their
experience to break people out of the
Matrix well there you go Chris Bennett
says what watch is Kyle wearing
it's a Seiko it's a Seiko with a cool
James Bond uh what do you call it a
little band that I put on cool they're
called NATO bands Brian Pike says we
live down the street from the Allen
outlet mall We the People
Raj OMG puppy says bellingcat is an MI6
front
well there you go so apparently it gets
CIA dollars
yeah I mean that's that's the report a
fairly fairly mainstream sourcing it's
just it's a way to launder intelligence
agencies lives into the corporate press
like I said minimally backstopped so
it's because they're here's how it works
right if uh someone from MSNBC reports
that the follower was a fan of me or
lives of tick tock we can't sue them
because they're just referencing a
security agency
and then we can sue them and they've got
infinite funding through the government
or whatever it is they're doing infinite
lawyers right so it's just it's just uh
they're they're Liars manipulators
they're just genuinely evil people yeah
it's like if if you look up even the
dictionary you find those people
Chrissy says Tim the next time you and
the show talk about religion and the
Giants you should bring on wendigoon and
or Aiden and Aiden from the lore Lodge
they know all about that also can I hear
Phil do his best Optimus Prime
impression yeah
Autobots roll out oh that was good not
bad yeah man that's pretty good for on
the Fly that was yeah you know that was
exceptional I haven't practiced it so
Sheamus can you do Optimus Prime uh
probably not as well she's like Autobots
roll out do it like an Irish guy do an
Irish
when we were in Miami we just kept
having Sheamus do weird random throw me
like different voices mashed together
what what are so do you remember any of
the ones that we did that were come up
with a new one man no I can't remember
but it was hilarious it was like
what do we have
are they all masculine voices yes like
Jordan Peterson and Ben Shapiro
you just found a hack my Universal
Health Care is bad for America okay
in 1986. Kuan Jin says pbd and Tim Cass
is the crossover I've been waiting for
so when does he come over to your show
and also any plans for future business
collabs I don't know yeah we went I went
I went down to Miami to go on the
valuetainment podcast with Patrick bat
David and it was uh it was awesome it's
a really really fun show I think we went
a little longer than we were planning
because we're having such a good time
and uh they're doing really really
amazing stuff down there in in Miami so
I'm really excited for what
valuetainment has their offer for Tucker
Carlson 100 million dollars was real
yeah we talked about what their plans
are what they're doing and they
genuinely were like yes they're gonna
they offered Tucker that money is that a
per year 25 per year I think it was 100
million over four years or something
okay
five years it's a 25 year 25 bump up
from what he was making at Fox is who's
making 20 a year there oh wow but he's
going to do his own thing and make more
money anyways he can he can bankroll he
could do nothing or anything there's
part of me that hopes that he gets with
with uh musk and actually does the show
on Twitter is that what they're talking
about doing well I don't know but I know
that that musk has talked talked about
content creators uploading video and
stuff directly to Twitter so it may
sound a little odd to people but I
wouldn't be surprised if musk was
thinking that because he must wants
Twitter to succeed and Elon Musk hear me
out uh Twitter needs a smart TV app and
you should roll that out immediately so
that Twitter videos and long form can be
played on TV like TV shows musk listen
to me none of these people are ambitious
enough just cheer me out what you need
to do is find a way to just project
Tucker Carlson onto the sky every single
night at every point in the world okay
right over China so the people living
under the CCP can't be deprived of his
content dude over the United States so
the sensors can't keep them off so Fox
can't fire him yeah you can do it get it
build a giant speaker and bounce the
sound off the Moon that's right so that
it reflects off the Moon Over the
entirety of of whatever part of the
planet we're all dead it's gonna hit the
brown note the left wants you to think I
can't project from the atmosphere I put
hand but but he's also got a he like he
has a whole gigantic constellation of
satellites coming in the air he could
probably do something with that yeah
just take over everyone's phones and
Tucker just appears in your phone right
but in all seriousness everyone please
do not do that please don't do that
please don't put anything in the sky
please don't put images in the sky I was
memeing if I brought that upon Humanity
I would be very upset with myself it's
like elon's watching and he's like
actually that was a pretty good idea I
don't know no I didn't mean to Tim
rewind take this episode down
I'd like to think he writes things down
on like a like a piece of paper he folds
it like a very elaborate paper airplane
and he throws it to some assistant that
just makes it happen sends it off to the
team Engineers that's his delivery
mechanism now Chris bevoto says my
eight-year-old son has Down syndrome for
the service guarantee citizenship please
continue to expand that passion for
special needs as I'm retired military
and he'll never be able to join also
still waiting for Phil to read my DM on
Twitter I use my name
well uh anybody can this service isn't
military when service guarantees
citizenship in Starship Troopers it
could be like working at a library or
something or it could be any kind of
could be cleaning of garbage it could be
you know cleaning up parks would be
planting flowers so it's not all about
military that's why it worked
hypothetically why it works yeah they
they always act like that was supposed
to be a cautionary tale when you watch
that movie but I watched it and I was
like the book wasn't there's some really
good ideas but how is it a cautionary
tale it's the weirdest thing like I
never I I know that the left often said
that it was like their fascists and the
guy who made the movie tried to make him
look like Nazis right but I'm like wait
the story is that they were the heroes
the bugs bomb Buenos Aires and wipe it
off the planet so then we respond to try
and stop them from doing it again oh I
don't I'm confused like they attacked us
it's it's 100 the same thing that
happened if you read Ender's Game right
it's the same exact idea it's like you
can't communicate with them right you
have no ability to negotiate they're
attacking you it's over you got to go
after them and try and wipe them out and
I don't understand what they're like
service guarantees citizenship is a bad
thing no even think about this like
people on the left would love
um what is it called uh Americorps where
they send people to go teach right you
go teach in the school for for 18 months
like you put some skin in the game well
when it was the whole goal when I was
talking with Vivek Rama Swami he just
said when you sign up for your secrets
when you sign up for Selective Service
that's secret Selective Service Yes Man
women ball to do it when you do you get
a voter card if you don't sign up you
don't have to don't worry about it but
you don't get a voter card and we're
also going to select you
not necessarily I mean I like that idea
though yeah I mean the idea we're
selecting you to do something the idea
is that only men are signing up for
Selective Service no one really expects
them ever to call ever again unless it's
a true catastrophe I thought I was going
to get called up you didn't think so no
they gave me a Gillette razor oh yeah
this is in the year 2000. I got a
Gillette razor and I was like okay at
any moment like really I mean I wasn't
old enough yeah I just I just thought
around I was like I don't know like I
don't know what would happen next but
then right after that was 9 11. yeah it
was a year later so that's the idea it
seemed like you can you can choose not
to sign up yeah and then you don't vote
I also wasn't that aware at 18. anything
to lower the number of uneducated voters
I'm okay with what do you think about
property rights is that a good one well
I mean I mean property rights what do
you mean owning property is a
requirement too no it doesn't make sense
there is there I think there's part of
me that wants to say property or
business owner and the reason I say or
business owner because you can start a
business on your phone you can start a
business it's legitimate what if you
what if your net payment in federal
taxes is positive that you actually have
a federal tax yeah that you paid
something yeah and you have a say but if
you don't if you're a net recipient of
tax money okay that may be the best
standard it seems like the easiest one
to me it's like you don't get to vote
for a living it seems the most basic you
you who are receiving from others do not
get to decide Beggars it's Beggars can't
be choosers that's it if I'm paying into
a system that goes to helping you
because you're on hard times you don't
get to vote how my money is taken from
me that's it I vote how my money goes to
you I get behind that and that guess
what happens it's it's a work it's a
it's a it's a fluctuating system if all
the people who are making money and
paying taxes say I am tired of paying
taxes we are hereby going to shut off
the valve then all of a sudden those
poor people stop receiving those
benefits and are now eligible to vote
you see how it works because if so it
has a safety net you can't go too far in
One Direction like the moment you cut
everybody off is the moment they say now
we're voting because we're not we're
we're we're we're Net Zero we're not
slightly net positive so it's it's uh
May the 8th and we just solved that
problem and that's a big problem so
there you go yeah the issue though is
powerful people don't want to don't want
to actually have to deal with it
ideologues who are too stupid want
conflict in the streets you're correct
so it's a good solution though Thomas
sidebottom says you are trapped in a
sealed metal tube with a crazy agitated
man making threats and growing
aggressive despite 911 calls you're at
least 10 minutes away from even being
able to leave the situation what do you
do
exactly
yep
looks I mean criminals are are never
expected to behave but everyone else who
has to suffer through their bad behavior
needs to keep a perfectly cool head at
all times it's the old why don't we pass
a law and make that illegal yeah so well
they already broke the law they're doing
something crazy and dangerous exactly
what makes you think they're going to
follow your second law yeah it doesn't
it doesn't follow
all right no name says Kyle I was there
with you at Lafayette Square after they
tried Burning Down the church still have
a paint stained uniform hanging in my
closet from that first night those are
some memorable nights at the White House
you the man
the 529 Insurrection it's called that's
right never forget 529 when far left
extremists tore on the barricades in
front of the White House tried storming
it set fire to a guard post and the
church forced the president into an
emergency bunker it was a day that the
left tried to destroy democracy never in
our country's history have we been so
close to having our democracy completely
destroyed almost happened they almost
hit the secret but the other closest one
was when you put the guy with the Viking
hat into the secret chair if you get him
into the chair wearing a helmet
he takes over the government yeah we
surrender all it's on this it's the
secret ink on the back of the
Constitution I think I think that's what
it says it says if you're wearing Viking
and this is why they were so scared of
him correct because the constitution
written on the back in pencil it says if
you were a Viking hat and sit in this
chair you become king of America there
are there are requirements for the
length of the horns and I'm not
confident that his were that based on
the angle I saw on CNN but it's possible
that he could have almost taken it still
it was a close call very close you wanna
hear something crazy I I sold my house
in Virginia a couple years back uh 21 I
think and the kid who came and he was a
kid he was young who came and inspected
my roof which was also frustrating
because he didn't have his own ladder I
found that very off-putting I'm like I
have to bring my own ladder to do the
roof thing and he was telling me he's
like oh yeah man I said something about
how I was there at Lafayette Square the
day that they they uh you know ran over
the barricades and he was like yeah I
spent the night in one of those big uh
chalice sculptures there's like all
these like big kind of like Fountain
things and he was in one of them and he
hid because the cops were around wow and
he hid there all night and I was like oh
you're a piece of garbage like somebody
should have arrested you and I was a
federal agent at the time and I knew
that they wouldn't back me if I tried to
go like well we should probably detain
you and have some questions it was like
I guess you're just gonna continue with
my roof so I watched that I was like I
cannot wait to get out of this area this
like that space near DC it's so toxic
and and there's no will to do anything
even when it's right it's gross called
Fifi queen says cast Brew request Broody
Mama blend half calf for Broody mamas
that want great coffee but also to spare
their little from too much caffeine
Broody mama I don't know I mean should a
pregnant woman have caffeine at all yes
yeah yeah my wife's she's drinking
coffee oh yeah it's you know what we
know they're not supposed to do is
alcohol that turns to be out to be the
case but we did have a lady sit with us
one time she was on her third glass of
wine telling us about how she was
pregnant and we're kind of looking at
her like this is a problem
um I'm fairly we figured this out in the
70s and 80s you're not supposed to do
that and she goes it's fine you know my
OB knows and I'm like knowing and
condoning are very different you have a
weird doctor that says oh yeah I know
you drink wine I guess you're just gonna
risk it yeah caffeine's not so bad it's
moderation like everything else
Winston Alexander says my New Jersey CCW
is pending told if I shoot a person
greater than 15 yards will be prosecuted
have duty to retreat out of home four
friends non-family or Leo to vouch for
me only can carry handgun listed on CCW
police chief interview is Wednesday wish
me luck it's just not even worth it man
that sucks yeah the cops the cops told
me
flee from your house and I was like I am
on the like there's only way out is the
is the back and it's a 20-foot drop or
whatever and they're like then you will
tell a judge you thought it was more
appropriate to kill a man than it was to
slide down you know the banister or
whatever or the the railing and they're
going to argue that means murder that
means you intended to kill the person
because there was an alternative and I'm
like I jump off 30 feet and break my
legs nope don't matter
crazy yep not America I think it was
like 16 17 feet the the back balcony in
the back of my house oh I have no doubt
we were built on a hill yeah so it's
like you walk in the front door but then
if you keep walking straight all of a
sudden you're seven feet up and then the
elevated garage was like 17 it was crazy
and that I'm like it's just nuts so I'm
like we got to leave this place can't be
here correct answer living by your own
uh by your own advice even I mean but
this is years ago too but still you just
you know it's that that's not a
sustainable situation like I'm not going
to tell people to do a thing that I
didn't do but people say like oh I have
families it's too difficult I can't quit
my job and it's just like I get it I
know it's hard I'm I'm not telling you
it's easy I'm saying one day they're
gonna come to your house they're gonna
smash the windows and they're gonna
storm in because you're going to be a
sympathizer or something and then you're
going to say to my say to yourself it
would have been less difficult to walk
Barefoot with my kids than to try and
break my kids out of a gulag you know
what I mean like I'm giving the most
ridiculous and extreme example that's my
point yeah if it comes to that point if
the riots come to your neighborhood the
question is is it harder to escape with
riders smashing windows and Fire bombing
buildings
you know or is it easier to just get in
your car right now and have nothing
either way you have nothing in one
circumstance there's violence in one
circumstance there isn't
JTV says Hey shimmy I heard through the
grapevine you have a classic car won't
disclose which type of year but my
dentist knowing you was a shock I know
why Tim visits Savannah now it's not for
my uh it's not for my old classic car
but um yeah I know who he's referring to
friend of mine awesome who is the guy
just a friend of mine from I've been a
savannah one time yeah I want a ghost
tour or something like that yeah I know
I actually wasn't there with with Tim
when he went no I went to that museum on
the boardwalk where they have the serial
killer stuff yeah a few a few years ago
my uh my car died and then I wanted to
buy something new and there was a super
old car that needed like a little bit of
of work on it so I just bought that and
then that's uh if you're not you're not
disclosing it at all no absolutely no
one can know it's it's genuinely I mean
I love it it's not that cool of a car
he's I'll just let him call it classic
because the audience might be like wow
anything over 25 years it is it is
technically classic yeah over 25 years
old it's a classic I think 50 is an
antique yeah it's my daily driver
all right our our favorite super chatter
the real Hydro PX says Tim I promise you
everybody will move if you find them a
new job a new home and set them up to
move stop riding that high horse listen
to this communist over here someone else
should give me things if you give me a
thing I'll take responsibility but only
because you did first dude
the responsibility is all yours if you
want to stay in New York City you don't
want to leave your job I got no beef I'm
saying just don't knock on my door and
be like help help it's finally happening
I'll be like come on man you know I mean
like come on what do you want me to do
about it predictable yeah it's like you
do you I'm not I'm anybody's anybody's
King I'm also not going to give people
money in a house or like yeah that's
your responsibility you know like look I
left Chicago I left New York well in
advance and then said here's why I did
it and here's what I think you should
too and if your response is it's really
difficult I can't do it I'm like okay
you know whatever I'm just saying what I
think you should do so if bad stuff
happens well then you know
there you go
bad things will happen
Jay Stewart says scotus has ruled School
searches are legal because local parent
now I'm just saying if I was in high
school and a teacher walked up to me and
said give me your phone I would be like
no and if they try to physically take it
from me then I would physically resist
there's got to be a limit to those
School searches are legal within certain
parameters they may be able to search
backpacks but I guarantee you there's a
higher degree of privacy that's required
on your phone because of the type of
information that's there there's always
like things can be legal and still have
limits and there's got to be some limits
there
we are changed says Shameless drives a
Honda Accord actually so classic so yeah
when I was in uh Community College I
bought a 1989 Honda Accord hatchback I
loved that little thing it's long gone
that was great it was great but like
aren't Honda Accords a step up like from
Civics so they're kind of nicer yeah
they are yeah what package what what uh
it was the it was like I think it was LX
yeah yeah it had this I love that little
thing it was it was 2013. so it was
already very old yeah yeah and I think
it was fun I had an 88 little Acura
which was almost the exact same thing it
was a six cylinder and it was a
five-speed it was super fun it was a box
yes so but it was you know it was a
three liter engine you could do fun
stuff with it and you could rev it like
you know double clutch and do all the
dumb things like a race car but it
looked like
felt like a little go-kart like it felt
like a little go-kart that was fashioned
up to look like an actual car it was so
it was super loud even when you were
doing like 40 it felt like you're going
way faster than you were yeah and
everything would Shake yes I love that
thing man I loved that little thing
about headlamps I will say on the on the
moving thing what really bothered me
about like the left in occupy was before
I got any attention from my work they
were like oh man you know this is the
perfect example of what's wrong with the
system see like you're like a mixed race
High School Dropout dude you're really
smart and you're hard working where's
your success where's you lift like they
keep saying pick yourself up by your
bootstraps but clearly it's not working
because the system is broken and then a
month later they're like he's a white
kid who was born the Silver Spoon he's a
trust fund kid he was given everything
he's ever wanted and so here I am like I
left Chicago because of stagnation and
crime with a couple hundred bucks cash
in my pocket and I was prepared to be
homeless and live in the streets and
that story is ignore board and then
later I'm like I left New Jersey like
well you're rich you're it was easy for
you it's like oh you know oof I'm like
okay whatever man look I'm you know do
whatever you want to do
low side goon says hey Tim my dog Coco
passed away early this morning she was
14 years old can you speak on the
emotions I'm feeling right now I
remember you discussing it in a previous
show yes so the way I describe it is
when you're when your dog dies when a
pet dies you're very very sad but that
sadness is actually happiness it is all
of the joy and happiness that you are
given by that loyal friend for a decade
plus being released in an instant and I
don't actually when when my dog died
when he was old and I was crying it I
wouldn't consider it pain what I was
feeling I was crying just like
horrendously but it felt good I don't
know how to describe it it felt good I'm
remembering exactly why I was feeling
this way was a positive feeling because
we think you know life life passes on
life is not I think lobsters are
Immortal you know you can have a lobster
for a long time but for for the rest of
us we get a certain amount of time yeah
so get a lobster for a pet and you'll
you'll have a great time but we know
dogs are gonna pass and we get a small
amount of time to to experience all that
happiness and then one day it's like a
you know a bomb of emotion goes off and
all that is released at once so that's
how I describe it I think I think it's a
good thing that that pain you're feeling
speaks to how powerfully happy you've
been made and another way I kind of put
it is you're paying back your dues you
were given all of that joy and happiness
and now you're repaying it in in a very
quick moment
it's bound to the universe man
but it's always a net positive you know
I always think back and it's just just
good memories it was totally worth it
and the question I I have for people
when they say like you know they're
hurting is would you exchange the 14
years you have with your dog so that you
were not crying right now of course not
never and then it's like the crying is a
good thing you know it's like it just
it's life that's how I feel about humans
too everybody wants to be younger nobody
wants a grow old and die and I'm kind of
like we are humans We Grow Old we die
just I'm not gonna cry about it it's
part of the bargain it's like I mean I I
will literally cry about it but I'm not
going to like life is unjust on like
flip over a table or anything I'm gonna
be like we have reached this point
there's something about people who've
gotten so far away from um from
biological death as part of the cycle
like you know people are so removed from
it they don't know where their food
comes from that something has to die for
them to be able to eat that they don't
understand that that's something that
this used to be part of everyday life
for every person until five seconds ago
being like the last hundred years being
angry at reality for reality yeah like
is so detrimental to any ability to
enjoy your life if you're mad because
you're subjected to a reality that you
don't get to control and that you're
going to end and and all of the things
that we as humans have to you know
manage to cope with and stuff if that
turns you bitter and angry you're going
to have a miserable life yeah you have
to worry about the things you can
control and the things you can't control
you have to do your best to let go
and mortality happens to be one of those
things you can't control yeah it's it's
a fact of life and although many people
try to you know they try to reduce that
and they're actually like a lot of
industries that try to you know there's
not a lot of people that understand that
grief is part of the cycle our culture
is trying to get rid of that yeah have
you noticed I mean that is a big piece
of almost all cultures especially ones
that have old you know Roots going back
that grief is part of the experience
even for very young people this is
getting very the industrial revolution
has consequences
look you can start reading Ted
kaczynski's uh uh what do you call it
his Manifesto and you'll be like I
actually saw someone man it's troubling
when you go like yeah Ted because this
was a bad dude because I remember when
he got wrapped up and you go thank God
yeah they got the bomber and then you
start reading it and you're like oh that
guy was a prophet he just didn't really
uh execute his ideas he just had a
terrible idea about what the post office
is for listen completely wrong you can
have fantastic my dad used to say this
uh good idea bad execution yeah I think
that's exactly it he was saying the
right thing he he took the wrong route
on how to uh deliver that message that's
right delivering it in a bomb is always
wrong delivering it being via
which is why it's funny with the whole
like Texas shooter thing I'm like the
milk toast show where we repeatedly tell
everybody violence solves nothing and
it's not the tactic for winning
political victories and then they try to
imply that we in some way would ever
encourage anybody to do anything close
to that stupidest thing ever
it's ridiculous and but again we not to
beat a dead horse but it literally is
just projection because they were doing
all that stuff about the trans day of
Rage blah blah blah blah all that stuff
before then you can look at all of them
yeah and then the trans person goes and
actually commits a a heinous act and and
they're like oh blame everything except
for the trans person and the people that
were firing up trans people as much as
they possibly could tell as telling them
there's a genocide going on and and but
the stochastic terrorists are Tim pool
because uh a Neo-Nazi watch this show
once maybe a Neo-Nazi probably not and
more importantly as you mentioned a
second ago too about what happened in
May in 2020 right and when they when
they when they go into the I think it
was was it May 5 29 529 was the day when
they actually did the uh the White House
John St John so all that that looks like
uh seditious conspiracy to to incite a
rebellion or an Insurrection to me
absolutely that that is Republicans
right now should be filing those charges
they're not doing it well they don't
control doj because doj is they could be
filing subpoenas and they could be doing
the 529 commission but they don't do it
I'm for that I'm for the 529 commission
make that Trend well I mean the majority
of the public is too actually maybe not
529 specifically but according to data
more of the public wanted the 2020 riots
looked into than wanted January 6th
investigated I did a I did a um kind of
a thought experiment the other day
because somebody brought up the
Charlottesville
um they're unite the right rally and how
much was that the dry run for what they
pulled off for the January 6th Story the
messaging there was so overwhelmingly
ridiculous and it was so one-sided when
the reporting that you ended up doing
the exact same thing but they did it
better with January 6th I feel like they
actually honed their game five years
later they executed even a better
version of that they had way more
substance with the Charlottesville
because there was actual there were
actual Neil Nazis there not many by the
way they were probably all the neo-nazis
that are on the Eastern Seaboard were in
that one place compared to the number of
neo-nazis that were actually a January
there's a lot more and it was it was it
was a arguably you could say that unite
the right was a right-wing you know
radical
uh you know uh event or whatever but the
January 6th Riot that was not a far
right radical event that was there's way
too many people there for it to be truly
actually far-right and radical I just I
love that okay I just want to mention
one more thing about Charlottesville
that that is what Joe Biden claimed his
motivation for running for office was he
said I ran for president because I saw
Charlotte's failed like shut up that is
not why you decided I wanna I wanna talk
about the Jake Shields fight challenge
with Mac bags so Jake Shields MMA
fighter Mac bags trans wrestler
biologically female five foot two Jake
Shields six foot oh so we're gonna talk
about that in the members only
uncensored show which will be live on
the front page of timcast.com in about
12 minutes so become a member by going
to timcast.com clicking join us
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends you can follow
the show at timcast IRL basically
everywhere you can follow me personally
at timcast Kyle do you want to shout
anything out yep you can follow me at
Kyle Serafin on Twitter on true social
you can go to Kyle serifin.com you can
see show that we do where we share a
government whistleblower stories which I
think hopefully turns the tide a little
bit right on my name is Seamus Coughlin
what I want to shout out right now is
the Saint Joseph's Novena that we're
praying for the working class in this
country uh in this time of economic
uncertainty for The Unborn and also for
our enemies like the people at voxel
Mulvaney those we disagree with and that
America will return to God so if you
guys want to go over to my Twitter
account it's one of my most recent
tweets has a link to this ewtnova EWTN
Novena I believe we're on day seven
right now so getting close to wrapping
up
I am Phil Labonte uh Phil that remains
on Twitter Philip remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can check us out on Spotify Apple
music and all of your YouTube links
there and I am search.com if you want to
chat with me I'll be in the comments
tonight I'll start doing that again and
uh you can find me on Twitter at
surge.com spell it out we have a new
documentary two of them that are coming
out very soon we've got infringed which
is Lauren Southern's documentary on gun
control and then we have another one on
the Federal Reserve in the banking
system you'll notice at timcast.com
there's a new documentaries section
we're going to be regularly producing
them maybe a couple every few months
hopefully we can crank out just tons of
awesome you know full-length
documentaries we may not be able to
release in Fringe tomorrow because we're
we're having our lawyer go through the
standard usage stuff and like giving us
notes so it may take a little longer
than we thought but probably within the
next few days maybe a week check that
out become a member at timcast.com and
we'll see you all in the uncensored show
in just a few minutes